two what up what up what up what up what
up
it is October 5th I'm back
after a short little vacation to
celebrate
mine and ela's 10th wedding anniversary
thank you thank you we've been together
yes married actually 10 years together
15 years it's a long time
it's almost half my life kind of crazy
damn yeah the best half
that's for sure he is Ethan Klein oh oh
yeah right it's Wednesday I forgot
sponsored by expressvpn about to say
shout out to sponsor quick
[Music]
it's just alone wait what how did Tom
Selleck get in there
this isn't my first rodeo
How You Gonna milk an ocean
[Music]
go go go go
go go go
stop it oh
stop it stop it stop it stop it
stop it whoa
[Music]
back in The Matrix
uh oh it's the hunt it's alive oh no oh
wow this is the ego Death part
cool
okay
what the [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
stay tuned uh oh Papa's in the house
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
got to go to break
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is like Willy Wonka's the boat
right yeah
[Applause]
is it raining
hey
is that an homage to you tripping out
during Sonic's at uh Ian
it had to be right
yes thank you for that boat ride through
Willy Wonka's uh chocolate River the
most horrifying
scene I ever saw as a kid freaked me out
never forget oh we got zilly's Anka oh
Haley zonka's boat right that was of
course brought to you in collaboration
of Ian and Zach when you bring two great
minds together anything is possible so
true it's Wednesday it's off the rails
sponsored by Express pien thank you
thank you yeah so uh me and Ila were in
Hawaii
I I was hesitant to say it because I I
don't know I don't want I don't like
ever to tell people
never know what's the new the meme don't
let people know when's your next step
never let them know your next move where
you go like you're like Turk
yo so Corky yeah oh you didn't expect
that did you I didn't oh man
but we were yeah we went to Hawaii it
was fun nice
actually we talked a lot about it and
this uh weeks see you next Tuesday
podcast
exclusive for members thank you to all
of our members love you so much that was
me
now it is actually an accurate picture
um
thank you Jay for the congratulations
I'm going to be hosting a relationship
ethics seminar next week oh which means
our marriage is doomed
um today
we have such a fun interesting unique
episode there's been an accumulate
ulation of stories about cheating
there's so many there's got to be and
they're all huge
and so we said damn some of these we've
spoken about some of them have updates
some of them we haven't spoken about
but we're going to be doing a tier list
here
we have uh let's see we have oh the
weights in the fish Scandal that was
pretty freaking awesome
there was a big fishing contest with
actually and what I learned is there was
a thirty thousand dollar prize so that
explains what the [ __ ]
that cheating was [ __ ]
they were stuffing the fish with weights
and there's a video of it Adam Maybe
video of the Year for me by the way
dude they were about that video is so
[ __ ] funny it it really is the story
wouldn't be really interesting at all if
there was no video yeah no not at all
but the video completely makes it
uh Adam Levine sliding the demons we've
talked about it we'll just rank that one
net uh Ned tries for in uh infidelity
try guys there's some interesting
updates there
cheating at chess there's a theory that
this chess player it's a really big
story he beat the world's best some say
the greatest player of all time uh
Magnus something I don't know Carlson
Carlson and Magnus goes you're cheating
bro I know you're cheating
and it created this huge firestorm in
the chess community and people have been
trying to figure out is he cheating is
he not cheating one of the theories is
that he stuffed up something up his butt
that's communicating a morse code or
something
that one is that theory is mostly a meme
it is plausible it's plausible
uh
oh yeah and then there's a this girl
um
Call of Duty uh what's her name Nadia
Nadia this one's really interesting to
me I've been seeing this one all over my
Tick Tock feed and and just on social
media this girl Nadia she's really good
at Call of Duty
which we don't we here on the H3 podcast
and the internet at large we do not like
gamer girls we say to them go home go
home
although Sam you're pretty good at
fortnite I understand
that's going to be a problem I'm gonna
need you to go home
on my way thank you
um and then there's also a poker anal
beads cheating scandal much in the same
way that they are accusing
the chess player of cheating
because the way I say that is because
there's no really conceivable obvious
way where you can just cheat when you're
sitting at a table with somebody
one-on-one so it's got to be anal beads
or something so there's a cheating
scandal uh there's dream showed his face
I obviously want to work that in so we
just said dream cheats that Minecraft so
it's still true it is still true you
know I Heart Radio cheating I don't know
if we talked about this did we talk
about this
the freaking I Heart Radio which is this
huge conglomerate they own a bunch of
podcasting shows they've been buying
views artificially inflating their views
to Rob
honest-to-god podcasts like ours of the
our rightful position as number one
maybe number two to Joe Rogan
no no no number one dude number one
the number one podcast in the world
thank you him
you're getting you're accumulating more
birds every time I feel look can you cut
the camera please I mean what is going
on here dude snow white ass looking I'm
quirky
are you ready ready for this where's
your dwarves Snow White oh oh does he
have he doesn't no way no way
yeah my little chinchilla or is that a
hamster
oh chinchilla wow he's got crystals he's
got mouses it's all happening over there
in Cam's Corner never let him know your
next move here absolutely not never
never never never
and then finally me cheating with young
gravy that's obvious we're just going to
throw that up there for um
for the purpose of
you know rounding it all out getting
some on the chair list yeah it just
occurred to me that the dream face thing
was such a big story I wonder if that
would be a great [ __ ]
thing to put in the title don't you
think oh my gosh yes because I got
thoughts on that people don't want to
know my thoughts everybody got thoughts
on dream face reveal which was way
[ __ ] too big by the way for it like
the the prevalence of that story was
insane
um there's a big moment for the internet
man that's it yeah it's a big it's a big
deal
massive dude by Ryan Cavanaugh okay I'm
fighting for your right to free speech
and we're focusing on dreams face more
people need to be talking about me
as always drive angry maybe it should be
maybe we should be
cheaters tier list and dream face reveal
I mean we could tack that on there I
think that's pretty good okay
or do you think lead with
dream face reveal probably not no yeah
probably not
let's go that's a dream cheating in
Minecraft people forget
we haven't we'll never forget it for
your right to free speech sorry the
thing about dreams cheating scandal is
just so embarrassing
people forget about it now do we have a
lot of dream stands in here I need to
know just I need to know how hard to go
on him or not
can we um can we do a poll I need to
know what I'm getting well there's
there's how many people in the crew
there's like eight of us so there's at
least eight dream stands in this office
really eight of you guys yeah stand
dream dude
I dream of a world without dream just
kidding not that bad I dreamed I saw my
maternal grandmothers
I dreamed I saw my maternal
grandmother's pubes
going around my neck
they went into my orifices and I had a
prostatal
orgasm from Grandma's pubes
you know how in hentai you can pretty
much turn anything into a tentacle
well that's what we did with grandma's
hair it's a little early for this you
think it turned it into a life-size
octopus tentacle
I've never done anything weird with my
dogs she took and she I let her have her
ways with her hentai hair tentacle rats
will dance for money if you pay them
anyway what about incels
what are we gonna do about them
we need to get more hair hentai
tentacles to the end cells I'm trying to
make a point okay wow this is actually
okay so nine percent yes ninety percent
no you can put up Napoleon that's that's
pretty much
zero because when we've done polls in
the past where it's like are you a human
being or you know like the most obvious
ones basically this is as polarizing of
a result as we've ever gotten bet you
have nothing so strap and dream cause
I'm coming hard
sometimes I go too hard and you people
like them
like Keith
I love Keith now great guy I like Keith
just a little soy
he is a little soy and he he gave us
good face like in that try Guy video
I could tell he meant it dude that guy I
mean I'll say he's the best at soy fit
nobody soy face like Keith from try guys
nobody
practically the father of soy facing
speaking of soy face
um I was just sent this
oh my God you guys stop it he's quirky
them I wonder how the guys are coping
during all this the try guys
that's really good yeah yeah oh is that
what they were getting that's a
thumbnail
bro we need to step our thumbnail game
up no way no
I think that they're getting a thumbnail
[Music]
yo his wife's a lucky girl man
[Music]
Becky you know what I'm saying that guy
cleans up he don't leave no crumbs okay
I saw a young gravy uh followed her and
she followed him back I saw that that's
exciting
wait he's gonna [ __ ] her yeah
young gravy is going for that MILF game
he's gonna spend a single second
is that wouldn't that be would that
that'd be incredible and you're talking
about you're talking about the Ned guys
yeah yeah this is this is a deals that's
a real thing that happened yeah yeah it
actually happened
this guy Ned's wife Arielle who he
cheated on all right now mutually
follows young gravy that is real he's
like he's like I don't even know who she
is but she's fine give her a fall
foreign
that was definitely for a thumbnail wow
okay
they should just Bank a bunch why are
you even taking thumbnails like
all right well anyway I'm not hearing
[ __ ] on Keith We Love Keith
I've already established that
um
so yeah
wanted to say again I don't know if I
press it enough but thank you members
see you next Tuesday's episode two is up
and it was it's great everyone's having
fun there everyone's doing good it's
just such a fun wholesome thing
we talked all about our big I complained
a lot about uh
the hotel I picked up on that yeah when
you sent it to me and we uh you know
cleaned up the audio a little bit I was
just spot checking throughout and I just
kept skipping around to different parts
and every time you were just complaining
about something else yeah I mean it was
it was a it was a theme of the episode
right but all in good fun obviously
either way ELO was laughing it's
cracking up she was laughing so I was
doing something right there you go
so there's that
also just a little preview
of our October release if you guys want
to see real fast work it
I gotta say just straight off the bat
I love this piece but this photo is so
weird his teeth are just floating right
there having a good time what's with his
teeth there man it's just a dental
office or we sell a clothes
got nice teeth show them off it's a
little bit Choppers dude yeah but anyway
it's a cool shirt uh this bow is too
tight
teddy bears this is badass by the way
this one's sick
and it says
you should always be your biggest
advocate
it's been a difficult year and you
should be proud of yourself for pushing
through oh yeah here to set some time
aside for yourself so you can focus on
your mental health and self-improvement
if you don't have your health you don't
have anything [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] cool sure I love that shirt
sick
this shirt's beautiful wow it's gorgeous
you know the world is [ __ ] have fun
while you can Amen brother that's a cool
one thank you uh I want the hat so bad
oh done cheers
uh this one bro super cool it's like a
patchwork
um a quilted patch it's really cool
and uh that's a little preview there for
you guys so thank you thank you also I
want to give a shout out
we're going trying to go a new Direction
with our
photography and just Marketing in
General on the teddy fresh page
and we just dropped this was our teaser
with October drop
this is it let's [ __ ] go
Sam you actually got this one right
I did
what do you guys think I mean this is
fire no I'm not Ethan Bradbery's at you
there it is October uh teddyfresh.com
October drop 10 a.m 10-6 oh what the
[ __ ] that's tomorrow Jesus so how was
the how was the experience of acquiring
this
um
expensive
they wait really he got you good huh oh
yeah well
yo yeah so there was another character
that was there and he was like hey come
come get in on this and so then I had to
pay both of them oh he invited him and
then you had to pay him and then I was
like well I took the picture so now I
have to give both of you 20 bucks so
this this was a 40 picture you got
hustled so what's your favorite
character to be hustle me for sure it
was Mickey Mouse oh yeah no it's fire
the Mickey we'll drop those he's good at
emptying Pockets oh yeah those Disney
guys but to be fair he probably you know
this is a
but you don't Cameo you pay more for the
for the uh commercial use he got me on
the he got you on the commercials yeah
it was the licensing fee that he was
Spider-Man what are you doing in
sneakers man that's not doesn't make any
sense at all
love that though Legend Love is posture
too he's leaning forward I mean he
nailed it
so it's a lot of fun thank you Sam good
job on that one
yes yes yes yes yes
um shout outs Nico we talked about
sneako didn't we
a little bit
yeah
snico was basically just a
manosphere red pill woman hating [ __ ]
loser want to be Tate yeah just another
one you know another off-brand [ __ ]
run-of-the-mill
uh insecure man
fatherless Behavior you know people
always go say about women motherless
Behavior has like an insult I think what
you're seeing here is fatherless
Behavior I think it can be equally
applied to men
uh if we're going to take that route
so anyway he got banned so we'd love to
see you see you all Partners see a
partner
snico is sharing his L's
both of his channels were removed do we
have any intel about
what put him over the top I mean I know
he was doing is this his man have a SWAT
uh
okay it looked like you have a Hitler's
stash but I think it's just an emoji
from the chat yeah that's unfortunate
timing I was like bro really uh uh let's
see this user this YouTuber's Channel
hosted social commentary that many
associated with Andrew Tate
Sam may not be aware but sneakers early
work oh he used to work with Mr Beast
yeah I knew that
do we have any intel if something new
happened or is it just the accumulation
I think it was just the accumulation
yeah
um
you remember there right we talked about
on the show there was that video where
he was uh
gyrating violently towards oh yeah and
that's the one we've talked about yeah
the Chad Chad Clips oh yeah Chad right
yeah that was bad yeah it was very very
bad and Nick is not green who put that
in his video I think that that was like
the Catalyst for getting damn Nick's got
to be feeling pretty good about that
hell yeah
anything's possible thank you Henry by
the way uh who says I'm a sushi chef
and have a lot of insight on liver chefs
tick tock
it made him raise an eyebrow
okay how are you gonna milk it out he's
I don't know how that's I'm still
wondering
Chelsea happy birthday God bless you
so oh he oh Nico was recently in
let's go
why'd you write Nico did I write Nico
you wrote Nico just so you could [ __ ]
correct me bro I'm sorry
I'm I'm medicated right now yeah really
what do you want
I don't know if I could say Tylenol
three with some yeah
coding it's a doctor prescribed medicine
yeah
yeah I'm chilling
okay interesting he's still um he's
still feeling the wisdom teeth thing
pretty bad he was he was obviously in a
lot of pain this morning so he's
Trucking through I don't see any
swelling no swelling's down for the most
part it's just anytime I eat like the
pain is like crazy but tomorrow I have a
follow-up appointment so you told me the
syringe truck saved you did you saved my
life I was it was like the fourth day I
think it was Sunday and I was in the
worst pain probably in my life and yeah
there was I didn't know what to do I was
looking it up online and I was just
sitting there and then I was thinking
about why is it hurting more than when I
started and I was like oh that's syringe
I haven't used that and the [ __ ] that
came out of my mouth was disgusting
isn't it [ __ ] there it was wild but
as soon as I did that I mean it hurt for
like probably 10 more minutes and after
that I was good wow yeah so thank you
wow yeah I'm surprised nobody told you
that because my doctor was pretty
specific about that um Tick Tock already
got banned what the snickle fans the
injured tater tots are out hard today
let's see what did we get banned for no
what do you guys think Miss info shut up
oh bullying harassment yeah that's the
game
the classic poor Andrew Tate here I peel
it usually gets turned over in like two
seconds suck a little bit of dick suck a
little bit of Dick my man I'm the one
getting plowed
yeah when I used to get that syringe you
put your head down over the sink like
this
and the [ __ ] that comes out is it's foul
I mean it's horrific yeah it makes me
disgusted to be myself I showed Lena
yesterday for the first time she was
grossed out really you oh you saw it
Lena
I've been seeing it yeah
what did you see come out of his mouth
holes
just a bunch of gunk
it's like a whole big mac came out
did it smell
I I don't know
I didn't smell you didn't take a big old
yeah next time can you capture that in
like a sieve and just smell it
afterwards yeah thanks bro for sure
maybe Zach could smell it it's actually
the smell Guy this is so disgusting I'll
give it a smile I'll give it a sniff by
the way Jeff Wick I hope you appreciate
what I'm doing for you
my hair is so [ __ ] out of control
right now okay Ethan and if I cut it I'm
gonna ruin the barbershop that's next
week right you're going to record it
yeah that sounds about right
but my hair is look at this look at this
hat it doesn't even touch my scalp not
even close
oh look at my hair I think the long hair
looks good with the hat though
I look like Sideshow Bob are you kidding
look how it comes out
[ __ ] I look like a homeless are just
uncapped geez Louise look at all that
hair man it's ridiculous outrageous
but that hairline on the other hand I'm
growing my hair back people yeah so um
farewell to sneako who has been banned
on YouTube hate to see it so sad
terrible you'll be missed uh you'll be
missed dearly my friend
yes indeed
Nico ladies and gentlemen and um
okay let's talk about then the dream
thing because Outlet we were getting
into that
and this was huge News man
uh when I was in
when I was in Hawaii this was popping
off
now
what was your guys's take on it and on
the face value see because it's like you
couldn't avoid it it was all dreams face
and all these massive creators being
like dreams face like let me show you an
example okay Anthony padillas is a
[ __ ] 40 year old man I know you guys
probably like Anthony and that's fine
I'm not trying to say anything bad about
Anthony I'm just saying this is a 40
year old man freaking out over what a
[ __ ] like 18 year old's face looks
like like just just like there's no way
that you care about he's 35 I'm older
than him yes sir
okay well then can you imagine me being
like no look at this child's this kid
I'm not 40 stop
it's not my birthday
stop
happy birthday stop clapping it's not my
birthday and I'm not 40. stop
[Music]
Zach kill the music
40's a good yo what the [ __ ] you should
listen to me Zach and many more yeah
when you were in your 30s [ __ ] loser
I'm not 40 though I'm still I still have
three good years of being 40. stop old
man [ __ ] you Oliver
yeah so um
I've fallen and I can't get up
that's not me I can walk fine
totally mobile
yeah so this is one I saw that I was
like okay Anthony come on
but again
you watch for yourself dream is calling
me right down
to face reveal to me
yo
foreign
wait you're Frozen right now holy [ __ ] I
have no idea what I was expecting
yo hi
look how shocked he is
it's just
it's just a guy's face and he's like a
young man he's like ninth and what how
old is dream like 22 or something it's
not that uh like I'm seeing dream is 23.
dream is literally 24. okay well the
chat doesn't quite agree but he's in his
early 20s let's say that it's like
so just to make this as bad as possible
let's just say Anthony's 40 and dream is
18. 23.
just kidding yes
yeah so um
it's it's just I felt like that one was
fairly tame I don't know if that was the
best example like he didn't he didn't
really freak out listen I know this one
was tame but it's Anthony Padilla she's
the oldest person on here this man is 35
okay and he's freaking out over a kid's
face it's just so stupid it's like bro I
know you don't care stop it Anthony
it just feels so dumb
also once you see what his face looks
like he's like the most ordinary looking
white dude ever like literally nothing
to Soy face over I was excited to see it
though I've never seen this content I
was so ready I bought Wi-Fi on the
airplane so that I could probably see it
I was so I wanted to feel in I wanted to
be in with everybody me too and I says
the man you get that [ __ ] face you
send it oh yeah I saw the face for a
second and I was like okay got it you
said that and I moved on you sent it
yeah
I can't believe that dream space anyway
we have all the reactions here guys so
we're gonna watch them all
but he's by far the oldest
wait did Hassan do one too yeah yeah is
it I don't see his honest I don't think
he saw it out as much as Anthony did
let's see see about that
it's like 10 different than I was
imagining but very close what the hell
you are so handsome bro
thank you wow you too
and then
look he's not a bad looking guy I'm not
gonna say he's not bad looking but like
I'm I Beauty's in the eyeball the holder
whatever they [ __ ] built his ass up
like he was Brad Pitt all these people
sucking his dicks talking about how
handsome he is and then when when he
came time to show the world his face
everyone like lit and this was [ __ ] up
granted people are like super mean about
it but I'm just saying the whole setup
the way that dream turned this into a
whole big event right where he called
out all these famous YouTubers and had
them live react to his face like
he set this insane expectation that was
going to be
only resulting in him getting bullied
that was the only outcome that could
have possibly happened you know and then
he's got all these people all of his
friends who are trying to be nice to be
like God you are so [ __ ] hot dude
that seemed to be like the running theme
of it
you're so [ __ ] hot dude and he accept
that compliment immediately he always
goes thank you bro
and I'm just saying you know so he's
just like a he's just like an average
looking white guy and I mean that with
peace and love of course
you know
so I don't know he set himself up to
fail here that's my that was my opinion
from the beginning I found the thing
just kind of weird and I felt a little
bit
isn't his looks not supposed to matter
uh from a dude I just felt the whole
thing just felt so weird
to me I couldn't pinpoint what was so
off-putting about this whole dream face
reveal hype and having people react to
it I think I might know what
he didn't call you no stop it
jealous I would have been like you're
[ __ ] jealous dude
you're like yo is this dream
[Applause]
she should have he should have called
you that's good content that would have
been great people saying Hassan uh it
was pretty swayed up I'm gonna watch it
then because he's not getting a pass
either it's like Anthony's him but look
at this face bruh
you ever see someone's face and freak
out like maybe if he looked like
foreign
that one meme can I show it which the
fat the fat black dude that's so funny
someone sent me that well I already said
I'm gonna show it
that would have been unexpected
yeah I mean I would have been funny
it wouldn't have been what
what are you saying Dan it would have
been funny oh okay that you're trying to
distance yourself
I'm waiting for the meme because this
this was going around I thought it was
funny like if this
you know a little unexpected but like
you he literally hit random generated
face white person Skyrim
you know
pretty vanilla man
which is fine I don't know I think it's
totally fine you're over you're
overheating no once again once again I
submit into evidence Ethan is the real
hater on this show
he set himself up he did this whole
[ __ ] thing about like oh look at my
face yeah I don't disagree with you on
that for sure he was setting himself up
too like PewDiePie if he had like a
sculpted beautiful Swedish face
PewDiePie is very handsome we agree on
that right yeah sure that's a perfect
face it's ridiculous it's perfect yes
and it's true the man is insanely
handsome so
um
I don't know it's funny I don't know
excuse me dream thank you everyone dream
face revealed
I don't know why you know what I'm don't
ask me to explain it or I don't I don't
I'm just saying it was it made me laugh
okay I'm sorry
please
it's the post and everything so
I don't know anything about who that guy
is but I'm sure he's a great dude love
that guy
um
so but yeah
let me show you the face actually maybe
it'd make sense if you saw his face this
is weird before you see the reactions I
don't know I don't I don't know how to
do this I feel like I feel like I was
waiting I was waiting to to figure out
how to do it and I was like
and now I'm sitting here like all right
well what do I do I just like rip the
Band-Aid off and turn around okay
obviously I can't just turn around yeah
there's a decent amount of Preamble here
if you want to see what there's a decent
amount of Preamble here if you want to
skip ahead to the review yeah it gets in
bed too
there come to America that's it that's
the face and like like he is yeah he's
Steve looks good he looks good yeah
actually you know what's crazy is um
it's gonna chiseled jawline yeah the
guy's got a [ __ ] mean jawline
chiseled is right wait you guys got a
tweet you remember when it was leaked
that
it was like a super big uh
larger gentleman
yeah I mean that's totally yeah it is
him yeah after you see what he looks
like which makes me like dude it's so
[ __ ] dope that he lost what looks
like 300 pounds or something
no he definitely worked super hard
by the way thank you for this message
dream happy birthday Ethan it's not my
birthday bro stop the sign down idiot 41
no
49.
happy birthday there we go
what did I do to deserve this disrespect
and many more to decline talk [ __ ] about
dreams yes so somebody actually did end
up leaking his um ID
he insisted it wasn't him and stuff but
it was definitely him and that's fine I
understand why he did that but
I I think it would be cool
if he
embraced this story because uh it's
fantastic the transformation is amazing
I mean shut up you know love that
inspiring stuff
dreamy
dreamy dream anyway so yeah that was
interesting but so here he is you know
just some white dude
he's a six out of ten you know I need to
see the whole body to give him a pure
real judgment there on the score I think
he looks awesome I've got one qualm
oh oh the nails oh [ __ ] sir we gotta cut
the nails before the face it was the
first thing I noticed too really I only
noticed you guys pointed it out yeah I
was about to send it but I was like ah
let me not be a no sense the first thing
I I look at Honestly by the way this
kind of hit home too I'm sorry to say
there's something there's something here
I'll tell you what it is
I wonder if dream has cats
yeah he was holding a cat in the video
oh right you know what it is it's like
he hits this one
angle on his face
and listening
listen it's hard to put yourself on the
internet I get it it's hard
um not everyone can be as accepting as
of their Beast
bestiality and not like that I [ __ ]
animals that I look like abuse
yo homie looks like he has massive hands
really let me catch you let me catch you
back a little bit see those mitts yeah
dang thanks for pointing that out let's
take a look
I didn't see the hands in the timeline
let it play
yo show me those show me those Paws
brother
you saw hand yeah I'm seeing it yeah
he's waving his hands around just if you
just let it play it'll happen yeah so he
hits I think what reminds us of Shame is
he hits that one angle and Shane does
that too where it's like just one angle
like this
just this side of his face I don't know
if you guys know what I'm talking about
hold on
um
here is
dream face reveal oh is that what you're
talking about you can see his nails if
you zoom in real quick
you at the beginning all right so let's
look here because that was the that was
like the home page before it's premiered
it was just it was this image of his
nails I see so you're just staring at it
yeah I was I I was given ample time to
actually absorb okay so what's your
criticism here it's just it's really
long super long yeah there's a lot of
white at the top
he got those uh cocaine nails if you
have the whole world watching huh it's
not as long as a cocaine now
or even a guitar playing though it's
long enough that I noticed it you know
but I think he looks wonderful he just
needs to bite his nails maybe yeah pick
up that habit
so so there we go the uh work on the on
the uh Nails there dreamers right from
our team there but besides that snake so
you're noticing his big hand here maybe
what's going on why are we pointing this
out
uh when we were watching the video
earlier
like five seconds earlier his hands
looked really big they're cool yeah bro
are you trying to make me feel insecure
or something I mean what do you I mean I
don't know I don't know if that's the
point of dream if you're hiring [ __ ]
on him
you think that's the whole point of
[ __ ] on her I'm jealous of the hands
didn't get the call
I didn't chiseled chin line
his age his hands I don't know oh here
here it is Avery
okay AB points out that he has giant
hands ladies and gentlemen I mean there
was one point where he was waving him
and they looked really big but then you
skipped back like 54 seconds and I lost
he didn't want to see it
they looked normal to me baby I don't
know what you're [ __ ] freaking out
about those are some normalized looking
hands I am I'm sorry but this is [ __ ]
up what you're trying to do to me maybe
okay try to tone it down just you know
you're sitting there you all [ __ ] up
on Cody and I get it you're feeling good
but you gotta take a step back bro
okay had enough for you today
my mom's gonna call me again
I say stop making fun of Ethan she said
that yeah when that random Channel
posted that Majin Buu highlight
uh she said yeah his mom saw the clip
where he said you look like Majin Buu
and she called him to chew him out she's
right I'm glad your mom told you that
and don't and he should give me her
[ __ ] number because it gets out of
hand I'll put our moms in touch and then
you're really [ __ ]
all right anyway back to uh
the dream shenanigans
they might also still do it you know I
love you guys but sometimes
they're a little is this hand huge it's
massive it is it looks like to me wait
what what love
I think it looks tiny it's just like
look oh I have a giant hand maybe yeah
some kind of Illusion it doesn't look
massive
I mean when you're staring at his hand
looks fine it's normal when you're
staring at small hands on such a
consistent basis sometimes you know you
can throw off yours in a little bit
here's the size of Amy's dick
laughs
actually actually Hassan would disagree
it is a crazy long penis yeah wait
Hassan wait has done senior year yeah he
saw it yeah long story it's a 12 inch
but I give it a light six all right well
I would I had it in the show for
tomorrow but since we're talking about
what's the context how did you see here
I'll show you
this was asking for some advice with
stuff and it just came off Hassan peepee
revealed I don't think we can show the
video oh he oh this is vulgar what the
the you play it but I don't think we can
watch the picture wait he's looking at a
sweatpants shot
from when you posted simply here here it
is
spoiler alert okay wait baby's penis
wait wait stop stop stop this makes it
look way worse
you're wearing pants
I'm gonna think we're blurring nudity
all right okay I'm wearing pants no no
later in the video it reflects it looks
like it's a censored version no I don't
like this version this is going to get
us in trouble
we need to show that you're wearing
pants okay okay because a Reviewer is
going to see that and be like oh it's a
naked man oh but he's okay
uh am I wrong you know I'm right no I
don't think so you know I'm right
I mean you could pull it up what was his
edited or was that an edited version
that was an edited version yeah so pull
up the original but then there's no
reason to talk about it for pulling up
the original oh oh it's a meme oh okay
bring it back
it's a meme come on bring it back
okay
I'll pull it up I got it here
foreign
[Applause]
he has such a long penis man I can't get
over this like it is a crazy long penis
oh he's wearing our shirt shut the [ __ ]
out Hassan Abby like actually Wild
did I miss it it's like skinny wait why
did you open now you you opened the
original amen what are you doing okay
ABC I did that everybody saw
is this not it no so what is the link
you sent me she's on some wisdom this is
the one that's not an edit
no I meant not blurred
let's go let's move on yeah
not even talking about me none of this
is even relevant it was an offhanded
comment that's turned into a whole thing
it says your dick is this big so the
dream is right okay Dream Is Right
Hassan is wrong my dick is small yeah
let's keep going I mean that's just
I asked
all right anyway that's dream space
everybody fantastic we got to do our ad
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was a great block of content there
huh
yes sir that's the power of live we
would have cut that [ __ ] out I thought
it sounded I was just trying to Alley
yeah no it was it was uh never mind we
got to do our ad
well I'm not done with this story
okay I was just getting started look at
Anthony
let me at least finish Anthony okay
Finish Anthony so here's Anthony
freaking out over a generic wipe by
white bite from Ohio
it's so [ __ ] weird talking to you
face to face after you're just a
floating voice
true that'll be soon hopefully are you
nervous revealing your face to all your
friends oh [ __ ] you're a real [ __ ]
human
are you are you nervous revealing like
are you nervous before you call
me
yeah
yeah up until up until the last two days
I had no weird I guess welcome to the uh
this was my just my favorite part
it's so [ __ ] weird talking to you
face to face after you anyway there you
go you saw it out a little bit
in the beginning okay holy [ __ ] I have
no idea what I was expecting there it is
thank you
let's do our ad
okay
thank you expressvpn for sponsoring us
today we love love love expressvpn
you know what's not fair the fact that
Netflix hides thousands of shows and
movies from you based on your location
and then has the nerve to increase their
prices on you I love that
unbelievable this is about
declaring war on Netflix
head
that's right
they've just raised their prices again
now you could cancel your subscription
in protests which a lot of people have
done their stock is down 60 or something
insane like that
or you could be smart about it and make
sure you're getting your full money's
worth by using expressvpn like I do see
you might not know what's on Netflix in
your country you might
having a hard time here today see you
might not know what's on Netflix in your
country that this is
am I crazy am I reading that [ __ ] up
see you might not know what that what's
on Netflix in your country is completely
different from what somebody in the UK
or Japan has on there it's the is it
goes what's on Netflix in your country
is and I was like what yeah I'm I can
see why I tripped you up a little bit so
you might not know that what's on
Netflix in your country is completely
different from what someone in the UK or
Japan has on theirs yeah I don't know
yeah I didn't even think about it I
haven't thought about that one huh using
expressvpn I can control which country I
want Netflix to think I'm in extra svpn
has over 90 countries to choose from so
every time I run out of stuff to watch
just switch to a new country to unlock
some new shows and right now
I'm watching on so did you know that
Netflix Japan
goes so [ __ ] hard you've mentioned
this yeah they have all the Miyazaki
films okay which you cannot watch in the
United States for some dumb ass reason I
think it's like a distribution IP
[ __ ] thing I don't know lots of ends
lots and outs but the point is
if you're into that I think there's a
lot more anime and Japanese shows too
which is the kind of stuff that I'm
really into
so if it's not available in the US all
you do is go to expressvpn change your
country to Japan and Bob's your uncle
you're watching that [ __ ]
you know here's the best part it's not
just for Netflix you can use expressvpn
to unlock shows on other streaming
services too BBC you know iPlayer it's
free and only available in the UK extra
svpn is also super fast and works on
your phone tablet even smart TV so you
can watch your shows on the big screen
with zero buffering times Smart TVs now
wow expressvpn how about that so stop
paying full price for steaming services
and only getting access to a fraction of
their content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com H3 don't forget to use my
link so you can get three extra months
of expressvpn free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com H3
it's restvpn.com h3get
uh three months free
by using our link okay
let's that's enough to finish an anime
series
a one piece if you watch it every day
I'll if you watch One Piece 24 hours a
day for three months you might finish it
all right there we go
thank you thank you
we're working through with people
we're doing it all right back to the
dream stuff because I was actually
enjoying talking about that until I
don't know what happened we got off in
the [ __ ] swamp lands with that
um
so here's some of the reactions let's
take a look
larae
let's take a look here
I'm so nervous
dream FaceTime
hi dream you're a bottom I don't know
why but I'm so what
did he say you're a bottom yeah
yeah is that real
I got in trouble for that and dream just
came out and said it
that's not real is it but he posted that
wait what the [ __ ] just happened bro
that can't what hold on his face no but
it's on larae's Twitter it's his
official Twitter yeah but there was a
lot of people just posting yeah
reactions just fake calls so so did he
not have a real one
timed
I'm guessing that
thanks guys
well what's the real one
was that the only one he posted I don't
know why but there it is he's a bottom
apparently according to dream not my
words
would never say that about anybody
uh wouldn't possibly speculate on such a
thing
it's completely inappropriate Carl
Jacobs from Mr Beast
um reacted dream is calling me right now
one Feast I'm about to see his face for
the first time I'm actually nervous all
right here it is oh shoot what the heck
you look like a baseball player you
scream baseball player to me you're
talking like a bit of a mullet I didn't
want to say anything but he's running
the mullet wait I don't know what I
expected you to look like you're
actually handsome this is this is my
stuff you're not supposed to be
attractive dream people are gonna be
pissed now thanks a lot I'm a normal guy
there it is uh handsome everybody's
building up the handsome narrative which
we love of course
Tommy in it in it
[ __ ]
tell me [ __ ] it [ __ ] dream it
says dream it doesn't look it says dream
oh my God is Tommy in it in in the flesh
no no again that that was that was a lot
I'm just saying now Tommy and it's a
sweet guy he has good fans and stuff and
he's you know we love him but he's just
a guy
um you know okay all right we get it
no
hello hi this is me this is what I look
like
so what are your thoughts I'm freaked
out well this is weird I wanted to pick
up and go pass and I was just looked at
you and I like froze man I literally
gave us the entire tour of you
there it is
let's go to Hassan's bro
that's the one that I really want to see
let's take a look
oh dude no dude I
said no dude no that's unacceptable
that's that's not acceptable
why not no no I thought you were gonna
be worse looking dude no no it's not
happening thank you no that's that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ]
we're gonna we're gonna kiss at
twitchcon
that's not that it wasn't that sort out
it's just being nice I can't go in too
hard to understand for that one I think
Edison raised my favorite
oh Addison Ray that's
did I skip that one yeah this is the
best one yeah this is okay here we go
music
is he friends with Addison Ray let's
just look at the weirdest
Creator combo ever
didn't they have a lot of like social
media interaction by like last year year
before and everyone was like Addison
does not know who dream is I don't
remember like some weren't they like
tweeting each other or something
I kind of remember that I'm looking into
it now isn't this one fake probably too
because it's just short there's no proof
it's actually him uh the reason why I
thought it was real is because Mr B said
I just saw his face as well and replying
to Edison wait what you think that she
faked it that'd be so bizarre I'm almost
sure of it what would you post the whole
thing
affected
what just to get on clout because it's
not a joke this is like January 150k
likes
Holly brought him like a sense of
comfort to have so many creators back
him before he did his face reveal so on
like maybe it's just a super nice thing
that like if that if this was fake for
Madison maybe it's like
she was throwing him a bone really her
audience but did he know like if she
just went out and faked this that I
don't know I'm that's crazy to me I
don't know about that but Sam was right
she did dedicate a tweet to him last
year and people were like how do you
know who dream is what did she tweet
um
dude there's no way that's fake that'd
be so insane to fake I feel so weird why
wouldn't she post the whole thing though
it's just a little teaser maybe I don't
know
oh she says I've been having wildly
vivid dreams again and he said question
question
you again
okay whatever
should we do a poll there's no [ __ ]
way this is fake
that
medicine
but he says he said Addison yeah
okay apparently people are out here
faking reactions to it
there's no way
it's too weird here is Bella porch you
guys said this one's pretty good
Friends of the show obviously
hi
you should have kept the mask on I'm
kidding I'm kidding no oh my gosh
that's awesome she's the only one
keeping it real
put the mask back on what the [ __ ] man
but you know yeah ultimately I was like
he's setting himself up for failure with
this because I think
The Faceless thing he got a lot of
little fangirlies who just they
fantasize that he's this perfect
chiseled faced
uh King and now he's just a dude that
looks like Shane Dawson
that concept of like romanticizing the
voice of the Minecraft player that you
watch like I will never understand that
I'll be honest I don't think he would
have got been anywhere near as popular
if he showed his face you think no
because they got so obsessed with this
notion of
yeah yeah that guy corpse Corp never
showing his face guarantee you corpse
husband is a [ __ ]
goat that dude is busted bro
I'm just saying I you know with peace
and love we you know great guy and all
that I just saying that dude is [ __ ]
hit every Branch from the [ __ ] ugly
tree
I'm just saying bro there's all there's
no way that guy's hands come
and I only say that because everybody's
got this little fantasy about him
but uh that dude has got you know
they just build so well
it's so hot right that's what it is they
just build very well online well Corp is
corpse a Minecraft player there's so
much more to it than that there's so
much more to it
um corpse he may I think he's just
general gaming and then he does his
music yeah he's a musician right right
right
something and people are saying I'm so
mean today
I'm just having fun you know I I'm not
saying I'm not saying anything personal
about them they're both everyone here is
nice and sweet and we love them just
trying to do an analysis
but yeah I'm saying corpse husband when
he when his mom gave birth she tried to
put him back in okay
just saying
that's normal right
but then she heard his uh his voice
mommy she said we gotta get you on
Twitch
actually corpse has been dead when he
when he gave birth to him he tried to
switch him out with another baby
but they don't that that's hard to do
these days there's a lot of people in
the chat asking who's breathing on the
mic hard that that was a breath that
corpse husband released as like a audio
file to his fans so that is that it's so
hard not to make fun of these people and
I do it with peace and love this man put
he tweeted out an audio file of him
breathing and people lost their mind
about it play it Zach
he literally posted that himself to do
some kind of weird uh uh what's it
called
being Hunters trap thirst trapping you
mean being shot fantasies
so I don't know and by the way these are
the biggest craters in the world leave
me alone
oh is this this is a real photo of him
yeah it's corpse oh he's he looks he
looks hot
yeah
his face is probably looking like
you know he's been pumping his hand to
get those veins that's him pumping
himself yeah so
yeah so do you think he was curling or
something to get his veins all yeah
must jerk off a lot he probably has his
tourniquet on and everything
he oh you think he like did like well
yeah died off dude you're so right it's
crazy how these guys know what they're
doing
yeah but there he is I mean he looks
jacked bro
doesn't that mean you're like dehydrated
if your veins are like pop in like that
is that hot to be dehydrated I don't
know
oh here's his hand this is his real hand
oh my god daddy
I got corpse hands I could feel those
hands all over me why is he so veiny
it's weird feel those hands off I hate
my corpse hands dude no your veins don't
look like that cam
his hands are insanely veiny in this
you're right he got me beat but I think
he was doing try to do something with
your hands to make it super Vania then
let's see
like squeeze it a bunch or something I
don't know how you do that
and I'll go
[Music]
This is Gonna Get Us demonetized right
here sexual content yes very sexual how
does he do that
yeah I'm trying to think sexual Dance
I'm trying to think what his uh
his face looks like
but I'm not going to do that anymore
because that's mean moving on
we love these guys they're great guys
uh but yeah people were super mean about
it anyway that like the minute he did
his face reveal on Twitter was like
dream ugly
or he's ugly I was like you guys are out
of control I'm so mean
but I felt ugly no don't say that fousey
I felt worthless don't say that bro I
felt gay what I felt that no like that's
just based on what they told me
hey
yeah um there it is uh whatever whatever
oh here's some viral tweets about it and
these are people's don't you can't
accuse me of being mean this is what
other people said
who this is some Rumpelstiltskin
oh [ __ ]
that's what I'm saying he set himself up
if he didn't make it such a big deal
people would be calling his
Rumpelstiltskin looking ass
dream after showing faith for the first
time who wants me oh
that's not true
people love dream how dare you
as a professional dream Mater I was
low-key worried but bro pulled through
looking like Rumpelstiltskin
these people are so wild man
it is funny though as mean as it is it
is funny you know
he's a beautiful man though we love that
for him
Society of dream put the mask back on oh
come on
that's that's mean report this tweet you
guys
bowling
every side of Twitter coming together to
collectively roast dream
oh [ __ ]
oh my god dream
who's this it's from Jimmy Neutron yeah
Jimmy Neutron got it okay
it's not the worst comparison you got a
nice jawline
ugly white guy
he's not ugly
and why we gotta roast this dude whoever
he is that guy's a king too stop it
don't be mean
I felt ugly don't say that foosi it's
not you it's them I felt gay
that's I don't understand that I felt
that note like that based on what they
told me it just cracks me up how he knew
so hard how he [ __ ] up immediately
uh he looks racist this one I thought
was very funny
you know it's funny okay sorry
I am of course a white supremacist he's
ugly was trending put the mask back on
was trending that's just mean that's
mean
if I was dream I delete Twitter for real
my aunt's wedding dreams downfall
[ __ ] people are as monsters
why are you such monsters man he's not
ugly
how dare you dream is ugly as [ __ ]
that got likes you can't even try to be
funny
dream stands forcing themselves to think
dream is hot
wow
I wonder who are these people fans of if
they're like dedicated dream haters is
there like a competitive mind uh someone
on the Minecraft Community who's beefing
with possibly a Roblox player Roblox
they were more Roblox demo crap the
Roblox communities coming together
I think people are in love with the the
fantasy of him that's it that that is
what I think white people like oh my God
he's looking because it's not what they
pictured in their head pretty much
nothing would have been would have been
good I feel like right nothing would
have lived up to the hype exactly
because everyone has their own version
of dream
you know short of looking like Jonathan
Taylor Thomas you guys remember he was
the heartthrob yeah I was so jealous of
him when I was really dating yourself
holy [ __ ] I was in Middle School
Olivia's like who
is that he was the cute boy from from
Home Improvement
was probably canceled by the time you
were born
no now he looks he has a jewel in his
mouth and the first Paparazzi pic I
found he didn't age well um because he
used to be so cute young
well it kind of happened with uh
Jonathan Lipnicki the kid from uh um the
Tom Cruise movie
you know
um yeah John McGuire Toby McGuire Jerry
Maguire and then he was in that movie
The Little vampires like he was a cute
kid growing up wait what this is what he
looks like oh my God
this is what I'm saying like look at
there's a jewel in his mouth that baby
face King syndrome I feel bad yeah look
I'm not saying that he he's handsome
he's successful whatever but
this always happens and it's and you
know thank God it does when you go to
high school
and there was this one guy that was so
[ __ ] hot that all the girls loved the
girl that I was in love I was in love
with was she was liked him and it just
wasn't fair and the dude now he grew up
he lost all his [ __ ] hair he gained a
long way and he is not looking good at
all now I don't hate this guy I don't
know him from what I know he's actually
a super nice guy nothing wrong with him
but I look at that and I say think shout
out Ethan in high school you [ __ ]
that guy you know what I mean I'm just
saying yeah the reason I have a Facebook
check in on these guys right right right
but when he was a young man
all the girls loved his ass and I was so
jealous I wanted to look like him look
how look how beautiful he was look at
that he and he got like the perfect
little part
look at this [ __ ] bowl cut dude that
was it my hair was too curly or polka I
thought if I could just have a bowl cut
the girls would like me
serious that's what I thought
you know
so there it is there was like a a
neighborhood bully uh and my
neighborhood growing up he used to beat
the [ __ ] out of me and my cousins and
then he moved away to Atlanta and he
came back when we were older and we like
significantly outgrew him he's like 5'4
and oh man my cousins just had the time
of their life roasting his ass oh that's
good good for them
it's good to get that but that you know
that's actually you guys should take
comfort young people who are still in
school
and feeling bad about themselves just
know
that in 10 15 20 years
that dude who you're jealous of is his
life's gonna be a wreck bro
I felt that no like that's based on what
they told me
um okay tone down your aspirations there
a little bit Jonathan they're way out of
your league buddy
um
I don't know where that came from it's a
very non-linear episode today
should I snort I'm talking about
Jonathan Taylor Thomas
25 years
oh right that's what most people would
know him from he was the voice of Simba
in the original original oh my god oh
that's fantastic yeah good for him he
did a good and then he grew up to be Sir
Matthew Broderick he's like he's like yo
now that I'm doing voice acting I'm just
gonna let it all go
yeah now we love Jonathan we could we
could Jonathan great guy did we all take
codeine today is that what happened I'll
take some you got any going spare I'm
out he's out he's fresh I got a
follow-up appointment tomorrow I got you
I'm just kidding you keep your medicine
jokes yeah
dream face reveal you know unfortunately
the Shane comparison is is a tough pill
to swallow corpse has been watching
dream getting devoured on the timeline
this was great
I get the meme I am a fan of uh euphoria
so I'm right I've got that joke I'm
right in there with you guys
um
yes he's ugly let's [ __ ] go
dude I gotta say he looks a lot like
Farquaad that's probably the most on
point comparison I've seen he looks like
two Shrek characters
who's the other one rumpel uh foreskin
oh that was the right character yeah
top you've actually if you interestingly
if you Google White it's love who is the
second result is that right love it's on
gift searches on all platforms like
WhatsApp Facebook Instagram Twitter
it's pretty interesting it's just white
and white and white male followed by the
dosey doe kid yeah
it's it's a good accomplishment I don't
mind it it's funny I wonder if the
immigration lawyer will accept that as a
uh
yeah because we have to fight this man
top of the top of the gift charts we're
working on getting love a special person
uh Visa is that what it's called love
something like that I don't really know
you're very special very special you're
very special you're very wonderful yes
yes yes
um and so we we have to get to prove
that he is famous he has notoriety he is
all those things obviously he's love
Yeah but I do think that this might
actually count for something if we can
find a way to yeah put me between your
legs I don't know if you can instruct
the uh officer reviewing your case to go
to giphy and type White
yeah I mean I'll do that yeah of course
yeah they'll understand
[Music]
Camp says he sees you as number one now
so congratulations I'm not joking he's
everywhere
yes thank you guys thank you this is
huge where's the [ __ ] Visa at that's
number one [ __ ] oh yeah
that's awesome
so that's far quad
yeah I was the first person to call
Dream ugly
these people are so mean dude
nah he ugly the first one
ah
he did say that he's um desensitized to
the hate though because regardless now
despite all the hate um he'll have more
opportunities now
that he can actually show his face sure
yeah it's certainly true that's true he
did a good thing I mean it was smart in
that
he built up this crazy huge audience
now but I whatever I talked about dream
enough [ __ ] up bro you're fine you're
like
God the resemblance is crazy here though
isn't it
let's go
yeah he also cheated on Minecraft and
the most embarrassing way possible but
there it is oh yeah hell yeah
there it is uh let's see Mark Rober
actually how old is Mark roberg he's got
to be old
uh and he has kids and [ __ ] which makes
this a little extra spicy 42. this man
is 42 even older than the joke age you
guys give me
does he have kids he does right
yes
okay
so here's a 42 year old dad
reacting to 23 year old dreams face for
the first time
is this really you
so can I I'm recording on my computer I
can post that I'm seeing dream space
right now
collections or that
yeah like zoom in hands Zoom
there it is shock all around the
internet is shocked but basically uh
anyway that's all a long way around we
have to rate dreams
cheating controversy which has nothing
to do with them absolutely nothing to do
with that story oh by the way sorry but
here I have to do this still
the fan art is so good
so the same little girls who were
fantasizing behind the mask now they've
seen the face nothing's changed
these are cute
this is a little odd
they get a little weirder oh that's
actually really good drawing we love
that for him
this one is pretty [ __ ] off the wall
now I'm getting a little uncomfortable
have you seen that the original picture
that's from a picture he's posted
hell no yeah it is let me find it he's
posting pictures already
yeah on Snapshot
oh I wanted to see that
I'll try to find it it's rare it's a
rare picture
it is it's a rare yeah I feel like I'm
the only one that I said no I can't find
it just okay so I'll have it on my phone
yeah just give me a second stand by for
Love's rare uh pick this one's I mean
I'm not I mean you know that's pretty
really good
perfect
this what's is this one a real photo
love
this I think it's the same just flipped
but it's from the same origin picture
hold on I I got it I got it and now here
now I don't know why people have to do
this
they cut out the first kiss from the
Vlog I got you guys who he's who's why
do they got to do this
isn't this [ __ ] up to have him like
make it out with another dude right away
oh
now I can maybe get some sleep without
melatonin
no you're still gonna need that
based on the reaction
of the internet
it's pretty pretty interesting
um
Bros who pissed together stay together
why are you doing that dude it's just
not necessary
stop it why is there so much fan art
making out with and being gay well he's
not gay right he's not made any comment
in my own sexual orientation
roommates by the way
on the picture oh that's so that's so
[ __ ] up
that's got to be very uncomfortable
doesn't that make you gay yeah this one
is um
it's really good it's good
super good all right let's move on thank
you so dreams cheating uh Scandal which
has nothing again nothing I do think his
is pretty good his is really good
because he hired a [ __ ]
mathematician
to prove that he didn't cheat knowing
he was a cheater that's next level it's
pretty good but we got him in a lot of
hair too yet so I I would put his at
maybe a for now
and we can move stuff around a little
bit yeah
yeah I mean it did result in one of my
favorite sound bites on the show go
ahead Zach
hell yeah yeah hell yeah that's what he
said when he broke the world record
Minecraft speed run right let's go and
then some Minecraft Community
mathematically proved that his run is
like one in a trillion odds of happening
right
then he hired a mathematician be like no
you're [ __ ] wrong bro this shit's
possible and then they're like dude
you're cheating and he had to come out
eventually and admit he's like oh I had
a program running I didn't know was on
at the time yeah okay dude
let's go
so pretty good hey so let's move on now
new character you know what um while
we're here I just realized there isn't
really an update on Adam Levine so maybe
that's another one we can kind of use
establish a baseline here well so the
Adam Levine one
I mean cheating's normal right cheating
it happens all the time right right but
what about the text message maybe pretty
wild oh and the baby name that kicks it
up at least a tear he was gonna name his
child after the woman he's having an
affair with and then when I realized
there was a lot
there was a lot of girls you were honest
with and then when you see the text
messages of him being like dude your
body's insane
just thirsty I'm gonna have to see that
booty I'm gonna need to see that booty
[ __ ] [ __ ]
should we pull up some of the tax just
to maybe before we place it
you are 50 times hotter in person and so
am I
oh yeah
no
I even with all that I think it's a c
it's just you know really it's just
cheating I mean it's it I guess it
doesn't have the juiciness of like the
whole back and forth with an MIT
scientist and everything so here he says
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that body of
yours is absurd you know he was beating
off when he said that
there's like this zero percent chance he
wasn't dick in hand when he wrote that
yeah
you guys think it's a bigger than C
because at the end of the day I mean
season on this chart is is that's pretty
low people are saying B I don't I know
but it's just look she's just cheating
it's cheating it's I'm not saying it's
not bad it's just boring it's like okay
you're just another cheater I disagree
no if it was just that I feel like the
text messages kicks it up a notch I
would say see
until I see a lot of people saying B
which I okay we can we can host it at B
for now I must say that I've had some
post-coital regrets about that phrase
for me it's it's the way he's spelled
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
seriously [ __ ] I may need to see that
booty [ __ ]
[Laughter]
dude what the hell
that is so embarrassed he for sure had
phone in hand and he's like you know
doing that post that was one phone one
hand texting oh without a doubt yeah
Lefty too you wouldn't you couldn't
possibly write something that
embarrassing unless you were right
really horned up that's just really
embarrassing
all right all right I think B's fair I
think B's Fair okay so we're on the
board
we're on the board we got a lot to get
to also I guess while we're here
the Ethan young gravy
Ethan young gravy I mean that's a d
wasn't even cheating
I feel like it's an S that's an isn't it
I think it's I would never ever ever
cheat on Ela it was a joke really
because
it's boring it was one pack it's
obviously F tier I think it was kind of
Juicy because it was like right before
your 10 year anniversary yeah that you
told her on the Spot while she was
watching the kids it was kind of brutal
she was watching live maybe we did we
did get this thumbnail out of it yeah
you live here watching
probably one of our best thumbnails eh
I'm seeing exclusively S's and D's I
think it's a d very very Split Decision
here it's either an s or a d listen
let's be real it's an S just because you
guys are having a fun time with it but
in reality it's a d let's be real in
reality I'm taking this seriously you
guys are not all right I'm taking I say
C I dare you
I'm gonna go just for serious Ian one
more time I'm gonna go D there it is all
right if Ian says so I can't really
argue with that well you guys do a pull
let's do a poll you guys want to do the
joke or you want to do the real thing
okay because I take this ball extremely
seriously it's a joke to you guys I see
how it is are we is it just between s
and D because yeah s and D that's it
there's nothing in between young gravy
versus taking this very very seriously
old Ethan test these nuts
say what guys Deez Nuts s these nuts
okay I get it
uh we should do the try guys next since
that one's kind of trotted territory as
well
[Music]
oh very split let's see very split bull
I'm saying D oh yeah it's close get your
votes in guys and please vote D this is
a serious
a serious tier list
and I understand you guys are trying to
do a joke
but it's having a big deal it's not s
it's not
come on you guys why are you doing this
this is ruining the Integrity of the
pulse absolutely a hundred percent
shame so stupid shame on you all
that's an S my friends that's an S I
voted us all right it's announced shame
shame thanks for trolling me
freaking trolls
all right now let's do the try guys
because we've already talked about this
but there was some juicy updates
um
as you guys probably all know the one of
the four try guys
who was known as the wife guy
it was basically his whole shtick his
whole personality
cheated on his wife with an employee
so he managed to blow up his private
life and professional life and one go
very impressive uh like it's a trick
shot baby oh yeah trick shot phase up
fazo baby he grenaded his whole life man
it's pretty impressive
it is
so these guys were forced to put out a
video explaining what happened from
everybody speculating
and uh well the good news is it's one of
the highest viewed videos they've had in
a while
yeah I mean it crushed on the views
hopefully they monetize that with
mid-rolls
Ned Fulmer so here it is
no longer working with the try guys
by now we're assuming you've seen the
Reddit threads and tick tocks and tweets
and news articles
we want to give you a timeline of what's
transpired and some transparency into
our decision making
throughout this video there will be
things that we want to say or go into
further but as I'm sure you're aware
there are some legal issues we have to
consider as we go through everything
on Labor Day weekend multiple fans
alerted us that they had seen Ned and an
employee engaging in public romantic
Behavior we reached out to check on that
employee Ned confirmed the reports and
since confirmed that this had been going
on for some time which was obviously
very shocking to us and we just want you
to know that the dude on the left is
ready to [ __ ] murder somebody that's
got a lot to say I mean I'd be busy dude
that guy [ __ ] them yeah so bad yeah
for what for what dude damn I'd pay to
watch Eugene beating that up
you stomp him so hard bro oh yeah you
said you like this guy in the middle huh
when I was in high school I had a huge
crush on Zach in the middle really yeah
got that kind of like he's kind of he's
got that pretty handsome and boy next
door what's what's his thing
silly silly one they're like old he was
like the cute one oh he's the cute one
like the um
one little baby one what's Keith's thing
is he the soy face guy or is he loves
fried chicken that's kind of that's his
Personality yeah okay cool he has like a
hot sauce brand and stuff like that he
always eats the fried chicken
from like everything he eats Fried
Chicken ladies and gentlemen huge
personality it's a it's a big part of
him and him what's his fashion okay yeah
he's an icon look at that yeah a true
artiste
so anyway uh hang on uh all of that
information was just as shocking to us
as all of this oh yes do you believe
that I'm still not sure that they didn't
know I mean it's just
it's hard to imagine they were at the
point of making out in public like I
don't know
I feel
I would say
and obviously I don't know [ __ ] I'm this
is just based off of Instinct but I
would say they probably were unaware of
the relationship with the employee but I
would
Hazard to guess they were aware that Ned
was not not a good guy
right that's possible they're probably
sick of his ass yeah and the reason I
say that is because after this news
broke there was a bunch because they
they um their whole thing started on
BuzzFeed I guess yeah like 10 years ago
and a lot of uh
women who worked at BuzzFeed were
tweeting
things like this is the least surprising
news wow I've ever seen in my life so
this guy's just a big old douche I think
so I think so so again I don't think
that they knew I don't think they knew
he was having a relationship with an
employee
but
I think he probably behind the scenes
had a rep as being a horn dog I think
you're right I think as business owners
and as they seem like decent guys if
they knew that he was having an affair
with the employee that's so unethical
and possibly illegal I don't know well
it just opens them up to lawsuits yeah
the the the woman like it was consensual
in this case but you know if she
wanted to claim that she was coerced by
her boss to have a sexual relationship
with him that's that's a huge deal so
yeah
um also I failed to mention that his
wife is part of the whole production and
they're all friends with his wife too
yeah and he's got kids L [ __ ] loser
this week
and thus began a three-week process of
engaging with employment lawyers
corporate lawyers HR PR and More in
order to make sure we were taking all
necessary Steps From The Jump we were
acutely aware of just how contrary this
was the values of the company we've
built and those of everyone who works
here
this
is something we took very seriously
we refused to sweep things under the rug
that is not Who We Are
and it's not what we stand for
we immediately removed Ned from work
activities and engaged in HR
professionals to conduct a thorough
review of the facts we also opted to
remove Ned from our releases pending the
results of that review
over a few weeks that's included
removing his section from videos
digitally removing him from others and
choosing not to feature him in our merch
throws honestly I want to give major
props to our editing staff for how
definitely they've handled that who do
you think we would have to edit out of
promo if we ever had to do that
what do you mean he says shout out to
the to the team for deftly editing his
ass out of the merch shoots and videos
you're asking which one of us is the
most like Scandal prone which we'll have
to evaluate edit out of a merch video
you know let me think here you it
happened Yeah Yeah well yeah that's the
right answer actually I'm actually
having to edit myself out of videos
pretty much on a weekly basis right
yeah nobody nobody beats me
nobody beats me people are saying a B I
don't think so I was thinking Zach
why me I know I know I know why what why
why did mine go there dude I just
everyone's saying oh no why why explain
to me why because you're Joker but
that's like what have you got oh what if
you got arrested for [ __ ] on someone
uh you wouldn't edit me out for that
yeah well what if they charge you for
like maybe there was a kid across the
street who was young and they spun it in
some crazy thing by exposing yourself to
a minor what the [ __ ] are you talking
I'm just saying if that happened I'd
have to edit you out what this is going
so far off
let's do a poll I mean I mean exactly
everybody's saying that why what what is
like the the uh the evidence there the
the the the because your Joker print
he's saying because you're Joker I tried
to explain it as best I can but you
can't yeah but it is well I think Zach's
the wrong answer I think Ethan is the
right answer to that question
well that's obvious yeah
but
I'm in the unsavory position people
saying Ethan's dad Gary that's possible
too that's actually already happened too
for Jimmy Lee
Jimmy yeah for sure
all right anyway moving on there are
several videos that we've deemed as
fully unreleasable you will never see
them and that is due to history and
that's a decision that has cost us lots
of money
there's a lot of videos we've deemed
unwatchable had nothing to do with him
it was just a really bad yeah
you will not be able to recoup that
money but it's a decision We Stand by
proudly
now we can't talk about the details of
the review but suffice to say we found
that Ned had engaged in contact well
conduct Unbecoming of our team and we
knew that we could not move forward with
him so on Friday September 16th the
three of us signed written consent of
the members of second try LLC approving
the removal of Ned as a manager and an
employee he probably got a fat payout
because I'm assuming it's like a
four-way ownership
so you have to buy him out speaking
you've got to pay them off to get them
out right
real quick there wasn't a there's a
comment about me being edited out though
Zach wouldn't be edited out you'd be on
the thumbnail
good point you can't believe what's that
Zach arrested for exposure to a minor oh
Jesus
we chose not to rush into the
announcement for a few reasons namely
there are real people who have been
affected and while we consider this a
company matter I'm there's just also a
family at the center of this
now we were always planning on a public
statement and we're working towards that
with our team but in light of rapidly
accelerating speculation we knew we
couldn't wait any longer
we're obviously incredibly shocked and
deeply hurt by all of this this is
someone who we'd built a brand and a
company with for eight years with these
oh we feel saddened not just personally
but on behalf of our staff and our fans
who believed in US
I don't know that we'll ever be able to
fully articulate the pain we feel at
this moment it's hard to re-watch old
videos that we love and are proud of
we're losing a friend we're losing
someone we we built a company with we
have countless memories with we just
made a TV show together it's I'm sure
many of you feel the same way I have a
question and don't hate me for it I'm
just simply asking because
it's obviously super hard let's say that
you know these guys have been friends
for decades their best buddies have been
through so much together is this
just a little bit
is it too harsh about like I lost a
friend like I mean you should they still
be buddies like theoretically
if your best friend was like yo I
cheated it's it's tough I think in the
situation they're in because if they're
spotted together in public they'll get
[ __ ] I feel like I feel like they're
protecting their image the what the
channel stands for and you know that
family Dynamic right but he also like
shot all over their business and like
everything that they put so much work
into like if you're gonna cheat why are
you cheating with one of the employees
that you hired to help
our business like that's [ __ ] yep yeah
it seems people are pretty split though
on the
hey yeah and they made it making it
sound like he died or some [ __ ] he's
still alive
but he yeah it's the if he cheated with
someone else
well if he cheated with someone else he
may not have been extracted from the try
guys yeah like they may have just given
them handled it differently yeah the
sleeping with your employee thing is a
big big big big No-No
not harsh enough some people are saying
we [ __ ] I hope that guy dies
I hope his house burns
I hope his I hope Arielle [ __ ] young
gravy
it's funny okay just a thought I had
because it's like they come in really
die
he's really hot here and I just wanted
to get you guys take on that
it's weird we're sorry that this ever
happened and we don't know what more to
say
there's also our staff of 20 strong who
they just don't deserve the negative
attention our brand is now getting
because they didn't do anything
but they're our family and they're some
of the most talented creative minds in
the world and our primary focus right
now is making sure they feel comfortable
and proud coming to work the work they
do never ceases to Astound us and
frankly there's just no world in which
we could have navigated all this without
them
now there are videos that were shot
ahead of all this right but we're going
to be editing net out like the new
season of without a recipe and we're
working with our editors and finding
Creative Solutions to the footage and we
also have some branded videos that we've
already committed to so when you see a
video that's sponsored in a few weeks
and you're like oh that's kind of weird
well yeah it is kind of weird it's just
how things are and that that's why
look I get Ned's about to be like thank
you to this recruiter we love recruiter
they should put like a digital uh dream
mask over him right
that'd be kind of cool
come join us at bowling night just
having the best time we're so happy
thank you to ZipRecruiter all right my
name is Ned Fuller
family man I love my wife put your hands
in the air
whoop just got a strike hey give me a
hug my best friends whoa I love my wife
oh my name is Dad Arielle get over here
I love my wife everybody it's zip
recruiter
just a preview of what that video might
look like
thank you that one stuff like this
happens there's going to be speculation
and gossip and we ask that you respect
the privacy of the family members and
employees who may be caught up in this
we also want to remind you that the
internet has a tendency to be a lot
harsher towards women than men so please
we ask that you exercise kindness okay
player
we love to hear it
although I guess he's probably thinking
about the producer I mean obviously yeah
I actually haven't seen a lot of people
talking about her I'm sure she's getting
a ton of hate though from their fans
yeah
I've seen I've seen more stuff about Ned
for sure but she did [ __ ] up though oh
yeah yeah she sucks too yeah I mean she
has a fiancee I Missed The Mark with
that one crazy
things will change here uh what we hope
is that within this there's also the
opportunity for positive growth and
better videos ahead uh but it's going to
be hard it's this whole thing is going
to be really [ __ ] hard
and we imagine you have lots of
questions a lot more questions right now
and you think he wrote [ __ ] hard into
the script because they're they
obviously pre-prepared this
so was that an improvised [ __ ] or do you
write that in
talking about Ned
I think it felt it felt impromptu he
went for it I think he just like do you
think he was gonna go for it before he's
like I'm a I think he was thinking about
when he was going to say [ __ ] I think so
drop the bomb just to show show everyone
that he meets business let people know
it's really [ __ ] hard
and I believe you I do I do too yeah
videos ahead ah but it's gonna be hard
it's this whole thing is going to be
really [ __ ] hard
he did it he dropped that up
number one trending
damn YouTube even YouTube's dog piling
on pornetto he knew where to put the
[ __ ] that's why it's number one trending
out of the first 60 Seconds
technically this guy in the middle he
[ __ ] because he dropped that [ __ ]
okay you think that guy [ __ ] I mean he
said [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] are all these guys
like married or and yeah
um Eugene has a partner I'm pretty sure
Zach
has a partner I don't know if she and
him are married and Keith and Becky I'm
pretty positive are married they're
partnered up but they all yeah they're
all partnered up
[Music]
um
[ __ ] it's really [ __ ] hard YouTube's
like [ __ ] Ned bro I'm trending this [ __ ]
now we imagine you have lots of
questions a lot more questions right now
and and we're gonna have more to say in
the future uh just right now we're
focused on bringing the best content
possible between now and the end of the
year and then figuring out if this is
part of the best content of the Year
sign me up because this number one
training baby 7.5 wish we could have a
scandal like this every week
Imagine imagine you've never watched a
try guys video and you log on to YouTube
and head over to the trending page and
see what's what's going on oh try guys
I've heard that name for years let me
let me see what's going on with the try
guys man totally
this must be a banger video number one
ironically it probably did bring a lot
of people new eyes to their Channel and
people back low-key I missed seeing
their faces oh interesting I think this
is going to turn out to be really
terrific we need to fabricate some sort
of Scandal here
yeah Zach go upstairs oh it's gonna be
you it's gonna be yeah don't we already
do that every week yeah we don't have to
we don't have to manufacture
unfortunately Zach uh
raped and murdered somebody
[Music]
it was found in a ravine with a body
I wasn't saying create a scandal right
now he uh I'm just trying to think in my
mind what what could it rise to that
yeah unfortunately he also you must
really think highly of me Ethan I'm
kidding kill the mics wrap it up
unfortunately
the corpse was desecrated
we found his DNA I have been watching a
lot of Dahmer in the b-hole
I mean that what I'm just saying that
people would watch for that otherwise I
don't think anyone would care
so I have to mutually listen I'm sorry
Zach but I heard Zach was listening to
the Jeffrey Dahmer soundtrack
uh a way to shoot a segment the other
day that was some killer Tunes in that
soundtrack The Ryan Murphy soundtrack
yeah I don't know some great 70s Soft
Rock soundtrack
I haven't finished that is it good yeah
Jeffrey Diamond it was Wisconsin I was
torn on it it's kind of messed up
because the victims but also
it was good but very repetitive you want
to go back halfway from beers with me I
watched the first episode and I liked it
and then when it ended I was like wait
there's 10 episodes yeah in the first
episode I couldn't look away but after
that it was just very repetitive
goes on and on AB we come back to my
place I have some beers with me
we'll have a good time we'll take some
photographs I'll give you fifty dollars
if you want to come back one day we need
to explain to the audience that John
Wayne Beats well it's almost the same
accent because it's that Midwest like
Chicago real quick Zack always says
could you say it Zach January Gacy from
Chicago I don't know where it came from
but he got me saying and everyone in the
office saying I don't understand it's
just one of those
oh hey Cameron how you doing you want to
come check out a stag film at my place
yeah don't you know we're watching the
Bears all right I've lost control of the
show
foreign
let's move on thank you Zach has not
done any any crime he's done nothing
just a joke here guys I'm just saying if
that news broke y'all be watching oh
without a doubt that that's it that's my
only point you know come back to my
place have some beers yeah you know
put on these cuffs
I dress up like Chuckles the Clown for
you
this channel looks like from there
that's it for now again more to come
some things may change we are just sort
of figuring it out all one day at a time
thank you for your support we appreciate
you and
we look forward to introducing you to
the next era of the try guys ahead
bye bye Ned you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass the
one guy this guy [ __ ] up his life so
bad it's kind of impressive see you all
partners
so if we go over to the tier list
for me
is going to rate pretty high simply
because
his reputation as the Family Guy he's
the wife guy and then he [ __ ] his
producer so wow that one's pretty good
see and in terms of scandals
it's great it's better than atoms
because of the eye care of his
reputation
I mean the yes the reputational thing
does add some points to me but see I
just disagree I think that this is way
more mundane of a cheating scandal than
the atom one because like we don't have
anything funny like
Ned wasn't trying to name his newborn
after the mistress or anything like that
so much content that is available you
know like with someone like Adam Levine
it's he's kind of unreachable but with
Ned and like this but there's so much
footage of them together and yeah it
wasn't his whole branding that he was
the wife guy he left yeah yeah I'm kind
of with Dan though because Adam Levine
is like an A-list celebrity
yeah you wouldn't you think you want to
do something like that but the texts are
so embarrassing for some of his stats
right but I think like there's all these
Mega compilations now of Ned and they're
like oh we knew the compilations are
good I'll give you that but by the way
there's a new video of them trying to
work it out that was Friday don't watch
this tell me what you think shout out to
TMZ by the way who never they gave us an
exception we love TMZ friends instead of
the show
foreign
and laughing eh
he loves his wife hi guys
hey are you guys working in working
things out
you are
well that's good to hear hi Ariel hi Ned
hey what's what's next I love how he
stands in front of the car and by the
way you're not pulling out
it's so cringe
okay
okay sure thing have a good day
she she seems to be in like way too good
of a mood now
I think that this was set up you think
yeah they called the the past I mean how
the [ __ ] I mean how the [ __ ] else would
he find them on some random yeah in this
Broad Street
they're not like but why would the type
of celebrity that gets followed by the
paparazzi anyways I mean obviously with
the scandal going on it's more likely
but why would um she want to portray
I don't I felt so what this made me feel
maybe I'm off is that she's in way too
good of a mood and it makes me think on
my earlier theory is that she knew about
it and they have they just had an
arrangement kind of thing well they did
say that the HR investigation had been
three weeks and that's
like on the 16th I'm pretty sure is when
they said he was terminated or they
signed that thing so it's been a second
but like you're I agree with you I I
think she's just embarrassed she's been
embarrassed online you know Non-Stop and
she's just trying to keep her composure
and not embarrass herself I mean of
course it's understandable she's sad but
she's just trying to you know smile it
off in public I mean I agree that she's
embarrassed she's got absolutely
unfairly [ __ ] in initial situation but
yeah like I if it was me I wouldn't want
to be seen with them no I if someone
called my brain is telling me that it
was Ned because he wants like people to
think that things are okay you think he
do you think he would have done that for
snakey possibly I mean he seems like the
worst so super sneaky and they have kids
too there's a lot a lot of factors
involved so she could just be doing it
for the kids you know trying to play
cool and
keeping things friendly yeah I don't
know if it like I said even if you were
trying to work it out I still want to be
seen outside with this [ __ ] guy for a
minute
you know what I mean yeah
he stood up for a little bit too long
next to that Tesla he's right right wait
let me put look at that again like they
were trying to talk to Ariel and he just
wouldn't get in the car
I know that's pretty nitpicky no no
you're onto something let's Analyze This
she seems confused she's like uh why are
you here
okay interesting now we go over to Ned
you are we're working on working things
out well that's good to hear hi Ariel hi
Ned hey what's what's next in your
career Ned okay what's next on your
career now my secretary
what is he supposed to say
um
interesting very [ __ ] interesting eh
um
fascinating gossip
so that happened hey did you guys do you
guys think it's worth watching one of
the compilations of all the old Ned
Clips or should we move on I've seen
some there a lot of them are reaches
yeah
yeah I feel like anytime any online
Creator gets into some kind of
controversy they could put together a
compilation that
I don't know Lord knows I got plenty
yeah yeah I mean how many of those clips
are reaching almost all of them a
hundred percent of them maybe
I've never
I'm a perfect little angel uh by the way
yeah Ela just heard unfortunately about
uh
my comment about Zach it was super
inappropriate and she's edited me out of
the
Teddy fresh promotional material
[Laughter]
this is the new shot here so [ __ ]
Shredder is so scuffed I did what I
could I know I know I'm not Chris
fortunately
um
you guys had to edit me out damn we're
getting material you got you got Stalin
dude I missed the market one
okay so so in the end on the tier list
I'm think I'm liking it more than atoms
personally I agree
I'm thinking it's an a
it's an a wonder I'm doing it I did it
with an S low-key
s
like how can you what what can be better
that we have you know uh we haven't gone
to the fish cheating yet you're kind of
right though Olivia because it was like
the perfect
way to ruin his whole life yeah it's
just like in terms of if you want to
indulge in an internet scandal
as a viewer this is a good one it could
have been better for there were like
text messages that said [ __ ] that's what
I'm saying is it's like duty at the end
of the day it's just your standard
infidelity
oh it's not it's maybe it's a little bit
more because you're right about the
reputational aspect but it's a better
infidelity Adams was standard infidelity
well I got I I must admit the audience
seems to largely agree with you to their
spamming s's well we could throw it to a
poll and and I think the choice is
really I don't think we need a or S it's
nothing but s's in the chat
you think so everyone thinks it is it's
Chad is always going to pick ass I think
so okay all right I'm I'm okay with s
for now
guys I'm so sorry I have to be so
[ __ ] bad this Gamers me too black
Cherry's running right through I know
I'll be right back
all right I didn't want to hear from
Arizona
I am my dear friend John Gacy ah John
Wayne Gate how you doing Jeff Dahmer
here so I was watching that documentary
it means I have been watching it and uh
we're not documentary whatever the hell
it is I show in the last episode John
Wayne Gacy is in it I was super excited
no way it's a crossover episode whoa the
casting in that show does he show up in
the post-credits scene like uh Daniel L
Jackson no it was like uh it was like
Avengers
I'm putting together an elite team of
serial killers do they cast the show so
well the guy that played Jesse Jackson
was phenomenal the guy that casted for
uh Gacy was like wow like spot on yeah
the mannerisms of the Jesse Jackson
actor was so good because I met Jesse
Jackson in real life and I was like okay
Flex he was at my graduate my one of my
roommates was on heroin and ate his
cannoli now that's a story what the [ __ ]
did he just say to me what my roommate
how did this go from Justice let's go
back to the beginning listen children
take a seat my roommate was on a heroine
who I didn't know was on heroin tell the
story in the midwest my dad was at this
dinner I guess speaker and uh my friend
he was really high
he goes
are those cannolis for like anyone my
mom's like Oh you could have mine she
goes just take it off our table
and my friend accidentally took Jesse
Jackson's cannoli and it just happened
and my mom texted me he's like dude one
of you dumbasses take Jesse Jackson's
cannoli and I was like yeah my boy did
my bad well you know on drugs over at
the Dahmer residence we have cannolis
but it's you know from intestines right
yeah it's a good time flavorful tastes a
little bit like pork but you know that's
just the diamond that's the Chicago way
that Milwaukee excuse you oh Wisconsin
sorry
sorry about that
should I you want to come to my
apartment take some photos then
fifty dollars
should I watch the Dahmer shows are
worth yeah it's very good the first
episode was good then he gets a little
repetitive I thought Niecy Nash was
fantastic at it she played the neighbor
oh yeah she's great
Evan Peters what a hung you did a great
job playing me didn't he was a study you
know
Callahan Auto Parts uh Tom Callahan I
sell auto parts for the American man
because that's just who I am well that's
um that's um it's not Callahan it's uh
Ray zolinsky he's the mommy boy
I make car parts for the American man
because that's just who I am
I want to go to Chicago I want to visit
Chicago have you guys ever been good old
time you should come to my apartment I
have never been to Chicago I have a
Ferris Bueller type trip out to Chicago
guys yeah you killed the car Cameron yep
oh you're even Cameron oh that's true I
am sad so it makes sense this sad little
boy yeah yeah but my people goes are uh
who's our Ferris
can I be George Peterson of course you
can
Alina's first vacation to gather the
rest of Chicago and I made a fake
permission slip and fake email that I
sent to our school email pretending it
was a school trip wait did you no shout
out yeah and Lena's like you are Ferris
oh did he do that not true false wait
Lena you're lying I mean you're you're
lying I just thought we were over this
go ahead
you're wrong what happened
it was a school trip oh well if your
family's watching that picture Lena in
Chicago in the living room I took it
so you took photos in the midwest yeah I
hit myself though
how's your bathroom break Ethan how was
it it was good I really was backed up
I have a 20 donation from Henry said Dan
is there even a chance
anybody know what that is oh no but I
love it maybe they want you to cheat
um
with them with Henry or even a chance I
said Dan is there even a chance Henry
Dan maybe there was an earlier Dono that
we missed thank you for the gift thank
you
anyway
um so thank you for sure I missed some
excellent chatter
oh yeah but uh alas I'll share I'll see
some comments that make zero sense to me
be a grand old time we'll have a pop
about it I think that happened last week
where you guys had like when I went to
the bathroom I saw a comment I was like
this makes zero like yes I don't
remember ever talking about this if it
makes you feel better Zach was just
talking like John Wayne Gacy a lot of it
didn't make sense so it probably won't
make sense to us when we read it either
good but it was a great impersonation
thank you there abdella have you
have you ever been to Chicago I haven't
but my family is from that area gotcha
yeah
John Wayne gave you the one that looks
like me yeah yes right you know you're
giving me reminding of myself Ethan you
know that guy that was the dude who um
would like
uh murder his employees that works with
him in construction sites yes and
dressed up as a clown and then you put
oh yeah he was he did clown and then he
put the remains under his under concrete
well no just in his oh yeah just in the
straight up yeah the guy
we used to watch stag films together in
his garage that gets out of me in
Wisconsin I remember he he was like a
big member of the community like
everybody loved him and [ __ ] he was oh
yeah he he went to prison for sodomy in
like the 60s and then he came out and he
like studied
what was it cam it was like sexual
studies or something like that sure
sexual dancer yeah what was it cam yeah
yeah he studied sexual dances back in
Chicago we did that we did the Tango the
titty Tango back yeah he almost got cast
in a John Hughes film out there
oh by the way first of all Gianna happy
24th birthday and a big shout out to
Dante new viewer you guys are awesome
Dante
[Music]
I hope you like Dante's Inferno because
you're gonna think you're in hell
when you watch this show every week meet
us at The Milk Bar hell subsection B
just kidding nice to have you okay let's
move on
so we got we're on the board here try
guys dream so this chess Scandal has
gotten really interesting
uh there's the chess champion of the
world Magnus Carlson you but you might
actually recognize him
there's a weird phenomenon where chess
became super popular on Twitch that just
really surprised me
it's not something you would expect but
so him and a few of the other really
famous chess players are pretty popular
on Twitch people say he's maybe the best
chess player of all time
I mean that he's apparently just
insanely good at chess
so what happened
was on September 4th 19 year old Hans
Neiman beat Magnus
at a chess tournament
which ended magnus's 53 match winning
streak holy [ __ ] that guy's a beast yeah
I don't know have you ever won 53 of
anything
let alone in a row
nah maybe Super Smash that's it super
smash 53 in a row you think yeah yeah
so um
Hans the guy that beat him is only 19
years old he exploded onto the chest
scene in the last few years
when his professional chess rating known
as ELO rapidly climbed into the almost
2700 range
for comparison magnus's rating is
28.61 so that's way up there
um the next day after Magnus lost
okay he tweeted out this
said I've withdrawn from the tournament
I've always enjoyed
playing in this tournament and I hope to
be back in the future
kind of cryptic not exactly accusatory
or anything but it's like why did he
withdraw that look at the video that he
tweeted with it that's what really
drives it home
not to speak if I speak I am in big
trouble
in big trouble and I don't want to be in
big trouble that's about I man I need
the access to that clip like how many
times would that clip have helped me
Zach can you pull that yeah I need that
guy on my shoulder like the little angel
you got it
and then we need a little devil too down
by it
Shia LaBeouf just going just do it
okay so yeah super cryptic it seems like
he's alluding to some kind of funny
business right right he had just lost to
this kid
so it seems pretty clearly something
about that
and I guess just uh because the story
has got a lot of twists as we're about
to find out but when this happened he
was getting a lot of heat for this
because the perception was that he was
just being a bad sport that he lost to
somebody you know a young up-and-coming
player and um that he couldn't handle it
and then he was like you know throwing a
tantrum essentially well yeah at the
time that's what people and anything
throughout the Scandal
it's basically been I've seen a lot of
people on both sides being like dude
you're obviously just a sore loser
or this dude's obvious this dude's play
is fishy
um the thing that's so weird about it is
like you're sitting physically
in person
right there across the table I mean it's
hard to conceive of a way where he could
have cheated
and and and and not be super obvious
right that's the part that's like it
seems so far-fetched
so he puts out that statement
the next day on the tournaments live
stream Hans admitted that he cheated
twice in online matches in the past but
claimed he never cheat in an in-person
tournament so this is interesting
who knows the truth so so I think this
everyone was like yo what the [ __ ]
everyone knew what uh Magnus was saying
and so this is him kind of responding to
the accusations so there's a few things
that they need to come to light
so first of all there's the the
situation with chess.com now people have
uh they have said that my chest.com was
was banned twice okay so this is what
happened when I was 12 years old
I was uh with a friend and I was playing
title Tuesday
and uh I was playing and you came over
on an iPad with an engine and I'm 12
years old and he said you know uh he
started giving me the moves I was a
child I had no idea what happened now
this happened once in in an online
tournament
I was just a child and
nothing happened then now four years
later when I was 16 years old during my
streaming career
in an absolutely ridiculous mistake and
on rated games after that I had another
when I was 12 I've never ever in my life
cheated in an over-the-board game in an
online tournament if they were in
unrated games and I'm admitting this and
and I'm saying my truth because I do not
want any misrepresentation I am proud of
myself that I learned from that mistake
and now have given everything to chess I
have sacrificed everything for chess and
I do everything I can to prove so I'm
gonna get sorry basically
so
and some I so he put out this statement
it actually didn't help at all everyone
was just like once a cheater always a
cheater basically I feel like it hurt
him I was seeing a lot there were a lot
of people that thought this was big of
him to to own up to whatever cheating
that he did do in the past well
obviously cheating at 12 is like no like
stupid silly right apparently when he
was 16 he got caught by the website
I there's I don't know that this website
is so serious chess.com I don't know how
they can possibly figure it out these
people are so smart that they have ways
of catching people who are playing
too good
uh yeah well I've been reading a lot
about it and this spoiler alert a little
bit to this story but uh they released a
72-page report uh yesterday yeah it was
yesterday
um
uh going into a great detail about how
many times he cheated how he cheated and
yeah apparently not only do they use
like computer models to see how much
your moves correlate to like what a
computer's advised uh move would be but
they also track like your um
you're clicking on the screen and like
changing tabs and stuff so say you have
like one of these AI chess engines open
in a second tab they can see that you're
going
somewhere else
um and then coming back and then making
a move and I guess over enough time they
can kind of correlate that and make a
pretty educated guess of what you're
doing
the one analysis I saw that was really
interesting is like
they track like a computer knows what's
the perfect move in every situation and
so they can track like what percentage
of your plays were perfect computer
simulated plays
[Music]
and apparently Magnus has like 70
percent
um averaged across yeah average and some
games he'll have a hundred percent like
it happens and apparently this kid has
been having like way too many hundred
percent perfect match games that
statistically
is almost impossible so chess.com
as Dan was saying issued a statement
saying they had banned him from the
website and that his history of cheating
was much more than he let on
and they sent him evidence of this dear
chess Community the last few days have
been tumultuous for many in the chess
community at this time we have reached
out the Hans Neiman to explain our
decision to privately remove him from
just.com and our events we have shared
detailed evidence with him concerning
our decision including information that
contradicts his statements regarding the
amount and seriousness of his cheating
on chess.com we have invited Hans to
provide an explanation and response with
the hope of finding a resolution where
Hans can gain again again participate on
chess.com we want nothing more than to
see the best chess players in the world
succeed in the greatest events
we will always try to protect the
Integrity of the game that we love
apparently this chess.com is actually a
big deal
it's where all the pros play yeah super
well uh uh regarded
pretty incredible that they're able to
build such a reputable and Vibrant
Community
chess.com here it is
let's play here let's play
I don't need to make an account or
anything
200 000 people playing chess right now
11 million games that's incredible I'm
yeah chess has had a big Resurgence in
recent years mostly because of the
pandemic and uh lockdown actually a lot
of people have gotten into it am I
playing I'm playing a real person right
now you sure are you might oh let's go
oh I'm black oh it's his turn go I'm a
speed chess player I don't know if you
know that about me
[Music]
ow let's go baby you're [ __ ] bro
oh I'm gonna take that big mistake
oh I got you just where I want you bro
what do you mean this is my level play I
got his [ __ ] his little
oh people are pointing out Queen's
Gambit came out too right you're about
to get checkmated oh the Queen's game
yeah so between everybody being stuck
inside and that show being a huge hit
and nobody else
nobody's checkmating me
wow Ironclad the Queen's Gambit they
call this the uh still in um
I am the Queen's Gambit don't you
understand nobody gambits like me
and I will win Against All Odds
no but I shall remain undefeated
[Music]
[ __ ] you just got [ __ ] destroyed by
my horsey
that was a huge that was a huge blunder
on another guy's part I was like wait
yeah that was really under bro bad move
yo you just got blundered hard
that you just got blundered so hard bro
that's what they call the Ethan game
what are you gonna do about this oh [ __ ]
dude you just got Ethan's gambited
watch this high level play I put this
here
check this out
you should maybe well you know what
no this is letting you do your thing and
scamming yep
hey that's cheating I didn't say
anything I didn't say anything and if
you start telling me move you're right
on chess.com you're right that would be
horrible very serious they do
[Music]
um
he's fuming from that Queen loss I have
no idea yeah he's he's tilted dude
yeah as I as I'm dominating this guy
so the theory is like how could you even
cheat
and one of the theories which is a joke
but it's actually not that far-fetched
is that he has some kind of device in
his butt it could it doesn't have to be
in his butt it could be in his shoe or
something but because they have a really
shorthand way of referring
to chess moves like E4 E5 so
theoretically somebody could be sending
him the best possible moves via like
Morse code or something or some other
code that they've devised between
themselves
that could be telling him the best
possible move so it's actually not that
unpausible and apparently they're saying
oh we need metal detectors at these so
it's it's
I think there is I think they wanted
them and stuff
um at least is my turn wait wait it is
his turn bro he's gotta think
all right I'm gonna offer a draw
wait
I'm offering you a draw at this time
how do I offer a draw
[Music]
I think you did
oh I did
yeah
dude let's take a job bro let's just
listen did he Rage Quit maybe maybe
they're not Hey listen you're not gonna
be able to defeat me
Ironclad defense I took your queen
huge dub on you
all right thank you man you know what
I'll resign you take the dub buddy there
you go congratulations
oh let's go Queen scan it watch out all
right what about Magnus
now you're gonna have to beat the Grand
Master of the office
who's that me oh are you good at chess
I'm the Grand Master of the office
that's true what does that mean have you
guys been playing he beat me well Ian
and cam played and cam one and then I
played Cam and I beat cam so that's it
that's the whole tournament I know
I'm I'm okay at it I've
played it quite a bit over my life but
I'm not a serious player yeah I don't
have that Force type apparently you're
supposed to plan like moves in advance
yeah
it's not how my brain works
that's true how shouldn't I grab you're
you're more instinctual than that you're
undefeated now we'd all just watched it
you know your strategy works too if he's
Magnus then I'm Magnum Baby Oh Daddy
here got a big one
thank you
anyway moving on
a few so moving on a few weeks later
Neiman and Carlson had a rematch
in an online tournament
and after one move Carlson quit the game
so he basically
got mashed up and he just resigned he
refused to play him yep
2700 talented kid and the rice couldn't
produce uh he got a good position
against Marcus it was a very very good
game it was probably an inspired game
you could call it but is it an obvious
proof of cheating definitely not I don't
think he cheated in the singfield cup
but everything else is still sorry sorry
Alejandra I just have to interrupt you
because the game started
um and Magnus has logged off what has
happened Magnus has resigned
minus so he played a move why did he
bother even playing a move I wonder you
know what I mean
or did he nuts yeah I mean I think it
was just an Impulse thing he was
probably just like you know what [ __ ]
this well he's right if he thinks he's
cheating that's the right thing to do
it's like
you know so that's interesting even
though he forfeit this game Carlson went
on to win this tournament what a g
even after refusing to play Neiman damn
daddy daddy Magnus he's pretty good so
on Monday Carlson finally put out a
statement long-awaited highly
anticipated
here he said my statement regarding the
last few weeks 200 000 likes so people
are paying attention here
dear Chess World
at the 2022 uh sink field comp I made
the unprecedented professional decision
to withdraw from the tournament after my
round three game against Hans Neiman a
week later during the Champions chess
store I resigned again against Hans
Neiman after playing only one move I
know that my actions have frustrated
many in the chess Community I'm
frustrated I want to play chess I want
to continue to play Chess at the highest
level in the best events I believe that
cheating in chess is a big deal and the
existential threat to the game I also
believe that chess organizers and all
those who care about the sanctity of the
game we love should consider
increasing security measures and methods
of cheat the detection for
over-the-board chests when Neiman was
invited last minute to the 2022 sink
field cup I strongly consider
withdrawing prior to the event I
ultimately chose to play
I believe that Neiman has cheated more
and more recently than he has publicly
admitted his over-the-board progress has
been unusual and throughout our game and
the sink field cup I had the impression
that he wasn't tense or even fully
concentrating on the game and critical
positions while outplaying me as black
in a way I I think only a handful of
players can do this game contributed to
changing my perspective so
when I first read this it's just because
this is developing from when I first
read this I was like there's a good
chance he's just being a sore loser it
kind of comes across that way because
it's like that's it yeah that his game
improved too much and he was playing too
good and not paying attention it seems
salty when when taken at surface level I
agree and that my yeah so that that was
kind of my impression I was like whoa
dude you might just be being kind of a
loser here
we must do something about cheating and
for my part going forward I don't want
to play against people that have cheated
repeatedly in the past because I don't
know what they are capable of doing the
future
there's more I would like to say
unfortunately at this time I'm limited
and what I can say
without explicit permission from Neiman
speak openly AKA he's promising not to
sue me for defamation which of course
right
[Music]
so far I have only even if I was
innocent I wouldn't I wouldn't be like
go ahead and say whatever you want about
me
yeah that's a weird statement yeah so
far I've only been able to speak with my
actions and those actions have stated
clear that I'm not willing to play chess
with Neiman I hope that the truth on the
spanner comes out whatever it may be so
there it is
mixed reaction to that but I think a lot
of people
were like dude you're just being a bad
sport
like you had a lot of support and you're
kind of the top comments your whole
point is that Neiman's progress
expeditiously over the board
and you presume that he cheated this is
preposterous more than a month you wait
to tell the obvious we expected more
from you like solid proof she did so
actually
Magnus put his kind of neck his
reputation and neck out and uh a lot of
people were very very angry at him
and as this story develops it gets a lot
more interesting actually
um
even though yada yada
so
what's with all the anal bead memes it
started off as an offhand comment from
the chat
but it really exploded uh so here's the
latest update Wall Street Journal
Journal article and this one just came
out
this is super [ __ ] interesting you
guys
when was this uh published it was like
yesterday I think it was yesterday
check out this headline chess
investigation finds that the U.S
Grandmaster likely cheated more than a
hundred times oops and that's what
Magnus said yeah he's like this guy's
been cheating
an internal report reviewed by The Wall
Street Journal alleges a previously
unknown pattern of likely widespread
cheating by Hans Neiman the player who
September victory over Magnus Carlson
has rocked the Chess World
wow this is crazy now
um what it alleges
it's a 72-page report so this is pretty
serious I mean it was practically
written by dream and his mathematician
is so serious it does have Echoes of
that doesn't it
actually chess.com
released a 72-page report yeah that's
who made this oh there's that Wall
Street Journal is just reporting on it
oh chess.com and then then it's real
it's 14 pages
it's even more than meticulous
this 14-page meticulously argued
document so I think the people at
chess.com analyze his play like they
would if it was on his sis on their
system
he's a variety of cheat detection tools
including oh it was on their system just
to be clear they're not making any there
still is no verdict on the in-person
cheating um this is purely about his
play online and that remember In that
clip he said I've cheated twice in my
life it was both in online tournaments
or whatever when I was 12 and I was 16
and they're saying [ __ ] you been
cheating they cheated 100 he's a Serial
cheater he's a Serial cheater which was
not public until
now basically right and you know this
dude is [ __ ] caught that's all I
gotta say here
over the board strength improvement from
age 11 to age 19. now this is really
interesting
here you can see strength Improvement
here's all the best chess players these
are all like Grand Masters over the
years I mean this is Bobby Fischer at
the top Magnus here so you can see
they're over the board it's like
fairly uh you know linear all makes
sense and then here's Hans neimans which
out it it eclipses even the greatest
chess players of all Yeah by a lot if he
wasn't cheating they would be he would
be potentially one of the best of all
time it seems like by far the best of
all time based on this
so that's super suspicious and uh
I would never and could never fathom
doing it in a real game he says so check
this out overall we have found that Hans
has likely cheated in more than 100 on
my chess games including several prize
money events what a piece of [ __ ]
he was already 17 when he likely cheated
in some of these matches and games he
was also streaming at 25 of these games
bro
so they have the day
and a number of games in the event and
number of games likely cheated all of
them wow or this one's half
that's crazy
so in all the games they detected he was
likely cheating
with prize money on the line
dude
bless you what's crazy about this report
too
is
not only did this expose this guy but
they kind of they kind of say it in
passing in the in the article but
apparently there's a number of people in
like the top 100 rating on this website
that they've caught cheating as well so
why didn't they ban them I thought they
banned well they do but they do it
quietly
um which this has started a whole
discussion in the chess community of
like
basically should this be talked about a
lot more openly because it's going to
only become more and more of a problem
we're at the point where computers can
like they blow away the best chess
players in the world like they will win
100 out of 100 times against the best
players they play Perfect now they know
that they're perfect yeah and so
at this point
for this to continue to be you know a
sport or a game that's played
competitively
um
they need to crack down on this [ __ ] big
time because it's very easy to cheat
they said uh the report was prompted
after Carlson's action at the sink field
cup prompted them to reassess Neiman's
Behavior
Carlson didn't talk with ask for or
directly influence chess outcomes
decision at all
I think what this really says and they
they go on to say that you know
chess.com has the best cheat detection
in the world
dude it just goes to show you that how
what a genius this dude is he just
[ __ ] knew his ass was cheating just
from playing with them and could just
feel it how unlikely his play was how
[ __ ] was off and he could probably tell
this stuff intuitively you know without
crunching the statistics that like his
Improvement didn't make sense his play
didn't make sense
and uh just seems like this dude
actually is a [ __ ] cheater isn't that
insane
yeah again there's there's still no he
hasn't been caught
in person so there and that was the one
it was in person
that started all of this that Magnus
played a game with him in person and
felt like he was cheating
um so there isn't really a verdict on
that still
maybe it was the anal beads as a serial
cheater I'm pretty much
100 on magnus's uh side and maybe it was
anal beads maybe it was one of those
some they actually sell those I think at
like there you can buy those you know
Corner shops yeah
vibrating anal beads if it was me you
know I'd probably put it in my shoe or
something like that
not not necessarily the bottle I think
they probably make them take off their
shoes because they do check like they're
aware of the fact that you could
like I I remember hearing from one of
these commentaries uh chess commentators
um that relatively recently they banned
watches because they realize oh like you
could easily have like an Apple Watch
vibrating oh or whatever Bella Simmons
thank you for the 50 gifted
thank you they really to make them take
off their shoes
uh uh I don't know
I would have assumed so because that's
such an obvious thing
and if they're not then they're saying
they do check their shoes yeah I mean
that's yeah
I would have to imagine they would
because if they care about this at all
by the way I know how he cheated I just
figured it out oh really I just [ __ ]
figured it out and I'll show you exactly
how he did all right so hold on hold on
where could that guy hide
a
piece a small piece of equipment that
vibrates hmm
where was that that isn't up his ass
it's not a Pizzazz okay in his mouth not
in his mouth in his hair his [ __ ]
hair bro oh this guy has
unreasonably big hair
it's suspicious oh
I have big hair too yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude sorely needs a haircut and he's not
his hair is so [ __ ] big he could
easily put a little sensor on the top of
his Dome that vibrates and nobody would
look in his hair that's very interesting
take it from one big haired [ __ ]
to a next I could hide anything in this
I'll never forget
my high school graduation night did you
guys do grad night where you went to
like Disneyland or something yeah I went
to Six Flags a guy that went to high
school he had big hair just like that he
got
pipe and a little dime bag that's what
I'm talking about stuck it stuck it in
the fro the little bird nest you could
fit a lot in here
how thick that is
so that's an interesting you know that's
a really interesting Theory but
certainly the butt if you're really
committed you could just put it in your
butt easy done
put it up your hand people put a lot
crazier things up their ass than that
sure certainly and for thirty thousand
dollars you know
so if that happened people have done it
for a lot less money too go ahead and
there are metal detectors when they're
going in because I'm just I'm trying to
think through like how I would cheat if
that were what
if that was what I was doing and I think
probably if it went off could you just
say like oh I have a like a metal rod in
my arm from like surgery I would need
they'd probably need to clear that ahead
of time really but like some sort of
evidence yeah if this serial cheater
walks out and setting off the metal
alarm you're gonna be like you know what
I mean yeah
if he did have a metal hit he'd have to
provide the medical proof for that right
serious business
there's a million places you could
probably hide it reasonably in your body
if you really wanted to you know what I
mean
butthole and hair basically that's it
yep armpit
they're gonna check that
you can check your armpit well they're
gonna wand you you know with the texture
or whatever
uh shout out Eric who ate shrooms at
Disneyland for grad night class of 2015.
let's go my man yes
well there it is
um so huge development just yesterday
chess.com is coming out and saying he's
a Serial cheater
and has cheated on prize money I think
the uh the irony I really like about it
is it seemed pretty clear from their
statement that they were motivated to
come out with this by
that video that we watched of him
ranting and insisting in all sincere he
really [ __ ] himself by doing that he
should have just shut up
well they said that they were
reassessing after Magnus
made his first original claim they went
back and started looking I think they
even but I think they specifically said
after his statements at the uh recent
singfield cup or whatever uh but I mean
yeah to say like I've only been cheated
twice on chess.com and they have like 72
pages on your app right by the way this
is super interesting here he is walking
through
security at the U.S Chess Championship
let's see what this is like this is from
four hours ago we're forfeited here
we're a little bit more five minutes ten
minutes he looks nervous he looks
nervous that dude looked nervous it
looks like he's got something up his ass
man he looks like when you give
groceries look at how he's standing yo
it does
oh that man
yeah your fake ID yeah because
this guy's doing a metal detector so
let's see what areas he avoids let's see
if he goes over his head that's very
thoroughly or if he touches the butthole
he's puckered up man he's ready
look at him dude he's flexing you're so
right Zach and that is an interesting he
looks super uncomfy yes you can't
breathe well he knows he's on camera one
breath in and he's swinging this whole
time if he coughs it's game over you
know you know what's suspicious to me is
that he yawned every time I've seen
someone trying to you know pass off like
they're not nervous I always see a fake
yawn actually yawning is a symptom of
anxiety it's kind of crazy when I had a
ton of anxiety I could not stop yawning
yeah it's crazy I didn't know that it
actually is a is a real I feel really
bad then because I used I used to make
fun of my cousin so much every time
we're around the girl he go
look what the [ __ ] is wrong with you why
do you always do that so now knowing
that it's anxiety and dude yeah yeah
you're a dick bro it's okay it's cousin
Tim oh yeah yeah miss him
rip yeah but like to avoid the metal
detector you probably have to put it in
there pretty deep
dude he's [ __ ] erect
you think he's chubbed up no no he's
like the ways yeah and the way he's
standing looking like a [ __ ] pencil
dude Jesus so let's see let's see how
awesome about it looks like this is
super serious actually what they're
doing more than I thought it would be
all right so he does the face
he didn't do the top of the head
that no matter what the time will will
start yes
I'm gonna mute it
dude he looks super nervous
checking the jacket
yeah he did not check the top of his
head
it's in his [ __ ] hair oh he's scanned
his ass yeah he scanned his butthole get
it in there no oh I mean he passed by it
okay he did not check it out look at his
face go back he's like yo he's like I'm
made it for real it's in his hair I'm
like almost certain of it that's the
only place you didn't Scandal and I bet
you they reviewed a bunch of footage of
how they scan and decided where's the
best place to hide it that'd be pretty
[ __ ] bold for him to try and do it
when he's under such a microscope right
now wait this just happened it said four
hours ago this clip came from
the clip was made four hours ago okay
well what what's the event I can look up
if it's happening right now yeah it
could U.S chess open is that what it
said
championship
this is such a great clip that this
exists it's so good all the faces he
makes after he walks yeah it's live
right now oh good it's live right now
I'm pretty sure this clip again today
that should tell you someone should
check his hair now go check that man's
hair if somebody's watching at the event
look go Pat that Dome yeah Pat that Dome
the champion what's up pal
Nookie
the chances that he's cheating are
probably pretty low but even with all
these crazy accusations
the guy checking still didn't check his
hair but he can't just start losing now
that'll look even worse well I think
he's a good chess player but just not
but is he a hundo percent good without
the computer I hope he loses a bunch
wow can we watch him play somewhere on
Twitch right now so we'll go check that
man's hair I'm dead seriously I'm
watching the event it looks like he's
not playing right now
he's probably watching us and going to
the bathroom and dumping his tracker
yo yeah he's got to shave his head if he
wants to play in further tournament get
him on Jeff's Barbershop too yeah
just buzz them
someone said by the way he won today not
anymore did he interesting well hold on
maybe I can rewind the VOD a little bit
and find his game it's not letting me
rewind I found a YouTube version
pass it w Dan
oh let's analyze this button wait here
is um
hold on here's a clip from from earlier
today
turns out
maybe it wasn't oh no what are we gonna
do
about the cheating potentially uh they
were right and how he is there ow ow the
duck about it do not want to get
canceled are you passing me the clip Dan
or uh well I'm just scrubbing through it
it's a long live streaming yes we don't
have to watch it I'm sure it's boring
I'm fine people
so there you go it seems like the The
Tide is turning oh no here he is oh he's
rubbing his head
bro let me see I found the money shot
he went let's see
oh he's twirling his hair he's twirling
the hair
that's a tell yo
that's for sure how shitty would it be
to be this guy like you just like just
yesterday
the report came out that this dude is a
Serial cheater and here you are sitting
down in a tournament across from him
probably took an easy L he's probably
like you know what he cheated it's fine
he should resign that'd be the gangster
move yeah let's refuse
well there you go super interesting uh
story
and I I think I'm I'm going cheater oh
noogie AKA our Saudi Prince give him a
Nuggie give him a noogie 50 gifted
subscribe we love a noogie
and the gifted Subs now means you get a
extra podcast every week on Thursday
only for members thank you so much thank
you for the gifted hello hello
so um I there's a what are we giving
this one this one's pretty good I mean
there's no obviously conclusive evidence
but all of the circumstantial evidence
is saying this guy cheats
I'm going to see really so many ins and
outs compared to Adam Levine just being
thirsty on him I can't believe you hate
on this Adam Levine one I feel like this
is criminally underrated to be fine in
my opinion being a thirsty weirdo
it's way more than that tried to I will
never get over naming your [ __ ] kid
after your mistress and asking their
permission I'm not I'm not processing
that it's just so bizarre I don't think
you are that's right you're not
processing it because that's that's for
sure no it's for sure that's for sure
real and her name is Sumner not summer
summer it's a weird like a Summoner like
a like a DND not no not Summoner either
some some nurse some nerve some nerve
some nerve yeah
and and has he made a comment about this
he posted his apology which is very
similar actually ironically to Ned's
where it's like I lost Focus like I love
my family also uh Ned's apology Maroon 5
it was just a statement doing a
residency in Vegas
after all this they announced they're
doing a residency in Vegas
uh
crazy but but going to Sin City baby and
stay loyal to his wife I mean it's a
good promo for it I guess in a way so
yeah if you like shitty music now you
know he's a shitty artist I don't know
so did Adam comment on the baby naming
thing no because that's no I think you
blow past that all right so what are we
thinking here I'm liking this one it's
pretty interesting I'm thinking it's a b
personally
I think that's fair like it's not as
juicy as try guy stuff
so what do you guys think yeah I'm
seeing lots of bees some people are
saying a I mean it's very good it's very
good you could write I mean you could
literally make a movie about this
ultimately if Ian's going D then I'm
going to eat too like I trust CNG why
why so low
I'm pretty sure that was the sound bite
just whatever Zack picks for me every
time
I'm gonna go D I think let's go well
let's do wow there's a lot Ricky might
need to go to the poll on this one do S
A and B between those three yeah
it's not ass chess cheating scandal is a
s a
or B
ask I'm seeing lots of A's and I'm
thinking it's an a you think it's better
than Adam Levine though it is it's way
more interesting he's just a horny
little [ __ ] freak
it's like you know how many of those
people have you met in your life they're
dime a dozen
now guys who put chips up their ass
cheated chest now that's interesting
Rachel said I'd rather see Zach Lewis
live at the Troubadour on January 13th
go Zach Lewis live at the Troubadour
January 13th thank you very much
and are we going to be having devices up
the ass during that event or yes that's
the only way you can get it
that's the ticket no it looks like uh
it's okay he's winning yeah a and I'm
gonna put it there at the a as well
it is right up there with the dream
cheating scandal it's like pretty close
with just how ridiculous it is
oh wait here Zach um Sam just went down
to
Hollywood and got another picture for
you
let's [ __ ] go that look live at the
Troubadour appreciate that January 16th
13th
oh it says 16. sorry
oh no
that's not healthy whoa that's all right
sabotage appreciate it cam though it's
very sweet
um so okay cool there's more cheating uh
controversies we've got the Nadia one
yeah we're um we're running launch we're
running low on time so the poker one I
will I will [ __ ] [ __ ] lose my [ __ ] if
we don't watch the fish video Ethan are
you going to a break fast tonight
I haven't I mean I've been breaking fast
every year I break fast every morning
no I'm not I'm not doing the fasting or
anything are you I mean I'm not fasting
but you know doing a break fast think
about ordering some Mexican food there
you go I was in Hawaii for like three
days I have had not met had Mexican food
that's not true I did have nachos there
that was yesterday
actually yesterday
also had fish tacos the day before that
okay well how was the food there was it
good the fish was great
it was all yeah so good
it was super super good man the fish was
great yeah we just ate a lot of fish
one thing I did not love we had a our
hotel
found rat [ __ ] on the couch okay and
then the night
or last night there I thought there was
a [ __ ] cockroach in the bathroom
Hawaii you're in the
Wilds man it's not wild it was a really
expensive Resort okay did you see
lizards
yeah lots of lizards love them part of
the experience
did you get yelled at for riding a
skateboard no skateboarding oh
laugh it up
real funny are you encouraging him
real funny how
make a big joke of it you know what he
sounds like Tom Hanks or something play
that again
don't ruin Tom Hanks
wow I hear it sounds like Jeff Bridges
bro foreign
no it sounds like the dude you're right
yeah yeah I hear the Jeff Bridges too
Walter man
Play It Again
that's Jeff Bridges oh my God
you know you guys all hear it dude side
note they have not responded to me yet
uh I'm going to San Diego this week and
I swear to God I'm about to just go to
the front desk Go full Karen they never
got back to you about it they there was
in like a support email that said uh
sending us more information and we'll
get back to you how much more
information do you need
okay well whatever you tried your best
and when he kills someone it's not your
fault oh I'm not walking away I mean but
yeah we'll see oh you're not backing
down oh hell no no [ __ ] that you're like
Tom Petty baby you're not backing down
maybe would you go down to the garage
and look for him I mean
leave the girls at home yeah I mean last
you know last resort I'm pulling Gideon
and like getting a bunch of people with
boosted boards and we're all gonna run
out that [ __ ]
like rough riders he probably wouldn't
be there he's not he's a [ __ ] janitor
not security we'll find him
that would be pretty good though yeah
lots of boosted boards he's I think you
die on the spot
I think he might just explode
the scene in Scanners that movie all
right so let's do the fish one Dan is
going to die if we don't do the fish one
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he's gonna [ __ ]
but I'm not actually I see the podcast
when I see poker it's up at the top
Call of Duty Josh dream
fishing tournament busted okay let's do
this one so again this one is awesome
because there's a video the video seals
the deal
I'm surprised so many people are out
here is comfortable cheating like it's
so scummy as an adult to go into a fair
play situation
especially with money on the line and
just to cheat cheat your fellow
competitors
I mean it's so embarrassing how do you
live with yourself knowing that you're a
[ __ ] cheater
right I mean it's so embarrassing dude
embarrassing this guy gets pretty
[ __ ] embarrassed in this video that's
what I was gonna say the way that he
gets confronted in this just spectacular
he's just so humiliated as he deserves
it yeah uh some context here the
would-be winner of a 29 000 Ohio fishing
tournament were disqualified after they
discovered they were stuffing weights
and what was super weird fish fillets
don't understand that inside of a fish
it seems like the weights are enough
yeah why why put a fish fillet in the
fish what are we supposed to think about
that no idea they'd be like it's just a
flesh fish fillet
it was obviously like cut perfectly cut
from another fish
there's a fish fillet in my fish
um
the director of the tournament
told CNN he was immediately suspicious
when one of the team's fish weighed
almost twice what he expected they would
dumb cheaters too apparently the walleye
in the bucket looked like they should
weigh about four pounds and the total
indicated they would have been at least
seven pounds
I thought there's just no way he said I
could hear the crowd grumbling like no
way there's no way I physically felt the
fish and I could feel hard objects
inside the fish
but what it seems so dumb but apparently
I read these guys have been doing this
yeah yeah I was trying to find a total
of how much they've won and I couldn't
find anywhere but yeah they've won quite
a few actually I think they the police
there's some actual criminal
investigation happening now probably
because of the money they got committing
fraud yeah
and so these guys could actually go to
jail for [ __ ] faking a fish [ __ ]
the moment when this guy's name's Fisher
yep
he was destined for this my man
the moment when Fisher discovered the ls
shooting was documented in several now
viral videos
Jacob one of the members of the
two-person team who allegedly cheated I
don't mean allegedly we really need to
add that
stood by silently watching as Fisher
dunked on his ass
and he screams we got weights and fish
boys
Zach you got at the end there's a little
sliver I I know I tried to cut it as
clean as possible but it's a lot of
overlaying like the scream happens right
when he tries to finish it late again
yeah you gotta cut it though I think you
gotta air
on the side of cutting the sliver out
okay
it's just my take no I appreciate it I
appreciate it you know we gotta get the
slivers out of there just saying just
saying
I it's like an old school Rumble what
goes down here man
uh they were set to win 29 000.
Fisher said he knew Ryan and his other
guy's name is
Kaminsky yep
they had won several tournaments
previously so here it is guys
we got weights and fish
ES
[Applause]
thank you
[Laughter]
this is a potential replacement for you
need to leave yeah it's so good yeah
everybody oh the follow-up
the follow-up after uh we got whites and
fish there we go
it's so powerful I understand it man
these guys got totally scammed
I was I was reading about this
apparently it's super expensive these
guys put a lot of time and money and
effort to come down and compete in this
and sure yeah it's just so [ __ ] up
[Music]
it sounds like the Angry Crowd in a
South Park episode it really does and
also yeah the prize money comes from the
entry money to join the contest
he's just straight stealing it from them
yeah
[Music]
we're gonna have ourselves a good
old-fashioned witch burning you know
what I mean it's like a mob outside like
Dracula's house or some [ __ ]
we gonna burn this witch oh man
I haven't seen a mob like that since
Salem
[Music]
the last time this may rednecks got
angry they tried to [ __ ] kill our
Representatives so at least it's there
it's just about fishing it's a worthy
Target this time yeah
at least it's about just fishing this
time and not trying to kill the vice
president man oh man
[Music]
so let me try and fight because
I mean kind of surprised that nobody got
violent and pleasantly surprised that
everyone kept it in check right they was
so angry that one moment the first guy
who figures it out
I'm surprised he let his ass cut that
fish open he must have been [ __ ]
and shout out to the cameraman man
you made all the difference
it's so funny how the sound bites of
this show kind of are like our own
language I've been saying we got weights
and fish all week and people probably
looking at me at Target like I'm crazy
oh that sounds clean Zach
there we go we got it we got weights and
fish
mm-hmm
oh yeah
yeah so there's another vid where uh
where it shows it more up close
apparently there's a bunch of videos I
guess all these guys were recording it
seems like it was going down you see
lots of people up in the side so this is
the third video that I had in the dock
the first two got claimed
um some like viral hog [ __ ] is uh yeah
inside out there wait they claimed this
not this one but the yeah I won't play
it but just to show these these objects
right here oh my God look at the amount
of Weights he took yeah exactly dude
you guys are Shameless man we got wings
and fit you sure do buddy here
it's so legendary there we go
[Applause]
God damn we gotta hang the president
boys
get those nooses out here
wow wow man so that's pretty that's
pretty good
is where's the video where he starts
busting out fillets that that part that
was the one that got claimed yeah well
can you just pull up like some
screenshots because it's just so odd
that they shoved yeah late uh uh weights
in fish fillets
like
what they could have put anything but
they put fillets of fish
but it doesn't look natural it's just a
fillet of fish
it's very odd
very very odd
[Music]
yeah I don't know what advantage that
serves over a
just a weight no a fishing tournament
forgive my ignorance to all the Fishers
isn't that just kind of like a game of
luck more or less there with the weight
uh well there's a lot of skill to
fishing
um but yeah as far yeah I think it's a
combination of both
right it's luck and skill uh one third
Sam thank you thank you for the gifted
gifted gifted 10 gift and we love wait
what is 200 000 IDR
it's um
200 000 of some current Indonesian uh
rupiah that is uh 13 oh my goodness bro
never got to Montreal live because of
the time zone difference in Indonesia
peace and love to the best podcast in
the world my man let's go red makes
one-third Sam is always in your Tick
Tock lives donating roses to the tater
tots oh that's sweet oh thank you loved
that for you thank you Queen here here
was the post that I saw originally on I
just want to say like freak out I do
want to say that's the first time I've
ever got 200 000 or 200 000 unit that's
pretty fire yeah
oh
all right so make it small yeah just
because this is the guy right here
looking very sad
go ahead trying to find the part where
that's the guy that cheated yeah oh
that's why he's like bro you are so
[ __ ] he's got John Wayne on his sleeve
ain't no cowboy
we got way in fish
hey I'm just trying to find the part
where he pulls out the filet
we got weights and fish oh another five
gifted from uh
one-third Sam thank you Queenie
[Music]
thank you for the good dude is that
ninja yeah whoa what caused that
wait no audio well I'm trying to avoid
us getting a claim so I'm just it's okay
though I think it's the video because
go back so when you first started here
this is where the flush is this is
what it's a Filet-O-Fish
it's got tartar sauce on it maybe to
mask it like to just put on top of the
weights right so if you're feeling it
you won't feel the ball of yeah I guess
maybe that was the logic like thicker
skin I mean obviously it didn't work
it's not very big it's like the balls
were huge compared to the filet of fish
yeah
yeah well well there it is uh
interesting fishing uh Scandal let's
check the board
so uh the fish cheater is now
the video obviously makes this whole
story
you've got weights and fish
not quite sure what how else to describe
that we have weights in fish
[Music]
all right that much I know
if you re-examine this controversy there
are and it's in its credit to his credit
weights in fish no doubt yeah there's no
doubt about that
so I'm wondering
where that weighs out
I'm thinking to be totally honest with
you guys as Plus I Know Dan loves this
one up above the S tier right but it's
it's just it's just weights and fish
there's no story there's no gossip yeah
one dude
and some weights and a fish I I think
it's probably the best media to come out
of this video like video wise people are
saying s it's not it's just a weight and
a fit but as far as con if that's what
we're going off controversy I I'd give
it an A but for video I'd agree with Dan
s plus it's a or s for me
I really would like an a
I'm feeling lucky yeah hater dude I was
I was gonna say C to be totally honest
what it's just weights and fish bro yeah
but it gave such a good sound bite out
of it it's just weights and fish that's
it we got whites and fish
if you if you have a prose if you have a
pros and cons list for this Pro is
weights and fish and that's it it's a
major Pro
oh why didn't ninja freak out because of
um
some clip here let me see this
reunited after all the years oh my God
oh see he was hyped he was he was a
little giddy he was on like a sugar high
because I like seeing his old buddy doc
I like the dock too man that's
that's not what I imagined when I heard
the sound bite I thought he was just
getting a bunch of gifts at once and he
was like eating them up with Pac-Man
dude this posted up or Ian sent it to me
and it was on our Twitter feed and it's
just like this is the most amazing thing
I've ever seen oh he posted this okay
I'm Gonna Come
okay I'm gonna come we got ninja saying
I gotta go yeah
nobody ever been that excited to see me
so I'm kind of jealous yeah I like it
all right we're gonna have to throw a
pole to this because this shit's all
over the place well I got a little pros
and cons list started okay Pros weights
and fish
cons what's the downside
well the downside the downside is
there's no like gossip there's no
backstory it's just one man there's
backstory he they they stole a bunch of
money doing this yeah there's there's no
laws there's no law exactly there's
scandals I'm sure a lot of people put a
lot of time into this and they practice
all year they've been going for years
and being shown up by these guys it's
like a movie that might be true but
there's no [ __ ] Texas yeah there's
nothing I can sink yeah but there is you
know what I mean it's a video with a man
waiting fish that's all you get and not
rocks it's just it's no it's no Ned and
Ariel I'm sorry not even close it's not
even I'm going off the sound by
potential and I'm going to retract my a
and move it up are you adding adding
cons yeah come on I'm just you know it's
so versatile you can't just rate it on
Scandal worthiness because of a good
sound bite but I think
think [ __ ] like it's it's just mwah but
this I don't think the sound bite value
should even be considered in the rating
I'll admit if there's text messages like
[ __ ] there's weights and fish it would
make it a little bit better but
I don't know I think the sound bite
should be considered I might have to see
that weight I might wait
I would do an in-between s and a if like
we have you know I'm just gonna be
honest with you guys I think it's a c
dude there's just not enough floor
it's so dry it's taking you to court
right now no I'm just trying to
transcribe all the pros and cons if you
compare it to these other scandals it's
not even on the same level
with the chest we don't even know beyond
the shadow of a doubt that he's cheating
too you know like with this we have a
Smoking Gun we got wheat and fish we got
weights and fish that's true the chess
we don't even know that's true there you
could be a super genius that's true good
point camera that's a good point
we got weights and fish we got weights
and fish cameras um um Kyle said the
people in this tournament are gonna talk
about this for the rest of their life
that is true
well so is Adam Levine's [ __ ] little
booty girl oh also
that's funny but the guy who ran the
tournament's last name is fishy
Fisher yeah Oh I thought there was
another one I thought there was Fisher
and then fishy
they're the cousins
ugh I don't know man I'm just being
honest with you guys it's a weight and
fish and we love that but it's just not
enough
I think it's a b or nay so let's throw
it to the pole I see the answers in the
chat are all over the place
so I think you got to do
s through C
we need the whole
the whole Spectrum here
Dan transcribe to kiss
we got fish we got weight and fish
wait to fish it's like a movie it rocks
Sound by potential it's
there's a Smoking Gun we got weights and
fish again the guy ran the attorney's
last name is Fisher those are the pros
fishy
right just not it's just one moment I
need a whole [ __ ] story sometimes I
need one moment it's all it takes like a
story arc one moment is it can only be
as good as it can be I will submit that
these guys have won in the past too so
there's a backstory in that yeah where's
the well where's the lore worst show me
the videos yeah I can't I can't speak to
that much but that's in the prequel of
the movie it is still developing because
they're being investigated by the police
which is pretty funny show me the
footage of the man and the fish before
all the cheating scandals came out let
me see they're Dynamic show me the booty
yeah who's gonna be in prison what are
you in for weights and fish
I got locked up for weights and fish did
TMZ cover this we don't look kindly on
fishing cheaters here in prison
all right
I'm throwing up the pole here we go all
right guys everybody get your boat in
this is important I'm voting C I just
don't think one moment of weights and
fish
I mean what you stand put the pros and
cons down
you really have to compare it to the
other things on the list I want to show
the the like Ned
[ __ ] the chess one dream hired a
mathematician to try to prove he wasn't
cheating when he knew he was cheating
this is insane [ __ ] this is just some
dude who's like I'ma put a weight in the
fish
it's not even a complicated plan
it was a fairly bad one at that yeah so
you know like it was captured which we
love
but I don't know guys I got bad news for
you Ethan yeah it is bad news the
audience does not agree uh not at all
this is an S tear that surprised me guys
that surprised me
someone in the chat said see the fish
died for no reason how does that feel
vegetarian yeah not great not great
yeah I mean that does make it more juicy
I guess
yeah
murder involved there's literal murder
yeah but murder nonetheless
um well I mean do you are you gonna give
in to the will of the people are you
going to veto oh they say s it's just
kind of shocking to me but there it is
there it is y'all are tripping balls if
you think this is on the same level as
Ned you got fished in ass
foreign
we got
his ass we got receiver and ass is that
we put it the only place
people saying bad people get the [ __ ]
out of here that's a great ball it's a
great poem
the results are bad
the poll is good
insane
well it's already getting pretty late
I'm yeah we've been going for three
hours but why don't we pick this up on
Friday sure we can continue because we
still have basically be interested to
hear ela's perspective on the fish
voting as well we still have the the I
feel like she'll back us up the Call of
Duty one and the poker one actually oh
and the podcast buying views there's
actually three still major stories and
who knows somebody May cheat Again by
Friday
and I might have a scandal by Friday
Zach just be good for the next week man
okay should I save
this for future use like should I it's
been done you want me to email this to
you add it to the court dog no you sure
can you make it a piece I'm gonna email
it to you
just so Ethan has it just saying I don't
need it okay
yeah I don't need that yeah no it's
already it's in here I'm not gonna
review that it's not I appreciate you
being humble but you got it yeah I'm not
going to open that email I'm not even
going to click it
alrighty well guys that was fun
it's really fun that was very fun
it's Wednesday so tomorrow you guys know
what it is it's leftovers day we'll be
here bright and early tomorrow morning
10 a.m talk about some politics I'm sure
we have a lot of juice stored up there
oh my goodness well I mean there was a
lot of juice stored up but then this
week has been pretty [ __ ] eventful so
I don't even know we got what do we have
it is this whole thing with Herschel
Walker oh because we didn't even have a
regular episode last week we haven't
really had a regular episode in two
weeks yeah so there's got to be a lot
wait hold on somebody just donated jcm
said Cav just bought 50 000 likes on
Instagram does he have a post with 50
000 likes well check we're well aware of
his uh habits
um we have many times 72 pages of
analysis
we've uh I'm sure people are familiar
with when you know big accounts like
some big influence or whatever post
something and says like it's a contest
and to enter to win all you have to do
is follow these accounts
um mysteriously
uh Ryan Cavanaugh's Instagram account
shows up in a lot of those guys so look
at this picture Britney Spears just
posted you can't put it on the screen
holy [ __ ] dude
what she's so wild
she is so funny it's just she I mean she
is fully nude and there's just a tiny
heart covering her vagina
she is on Instagram yeah it's at the top
of my page on Instagram first thing I
see when I opened it okay Brit get get
it look at that and just give me your
snap judgment on that because it shocked
me man
that is fairly shocking it looks like it
yeah I've got weights and fishing we got
weights and fish why did she changed her
name on her Instagram page to channel
eight
oh she's doing a little avant-garde
field reporting in the tradition of
Andrew Callahan channel right
um by the way
are you able to see kav kev's he blocked
me so I'm not able to look there's so
many likes yeah I'm not seeing the
specific post the last like six have
exactly around 35k that's awesome yeah
but yeah what are the comments
uh the comments let me see I'll take
another look best of the best best of
the best fire let's see keep it up bro
keep it up what was the post on that
they're saying keep it up I bet all
right so excited to share the first
teaser for their new movie keep it up
kill House movie keep it up keep it up
uh check DM fire emojis here before this
hits millions of views you know that's a
very common one I always see a lot of
people always say that first hand
experience this is what I was waiting on
with the trophy emoji
uh what we've been waiting for fire
Emoji definitely uh you always deliver
an outstanding work you always deliver a
outstanding work keep them coming yeah
there's no way this is one of the best
things I've seen it's so weird how these
are all so General and so wild uh got
this on repeat
always killing it you guys
the teaser trailer for the skill House
movie I've just been looping for the
last 10 hours actually that's probably
true because that same Bop farmer is
probably uh juicing the views on that
too yeah actually I go ahead baby
allegedly in Minecraft by the way
absolute gorgeous this is an absolute
gorgeous yeah Ryan Cavanaugh is putting
together a new
production company that I'm sure more
than any of his other businesses is
going to bankrupt and be a total
Financial ruin yeah
um too much wine sorry I was looking for
it's called the quad
I was looking forward to telling you
guys about it but we'll probably have to
wait till Friday but
uh yeah he's called it
the quad
is supposed to release three to five uh
genre films per year with a budget
ranging to the from 3 to 12 million
focus is horror Thriller American Comedy
and love story The Quad is currently in
post-production of scale house
influencers so it's all movies
surrounding influencers which if you've
been in the influence space you know
famously always do extremely well
extremely well influencer movies are
pretty much a Surefire way to make well
they also have 50 Cent involved
they got very he's like he's in this
movie
so here just check it out the
influencers they have signed Charlie
demilio Bryce Hall and King Bach King
bed batch oh batch
um and the Charlie demilio movie that
they're doing it's produced co-produced
by
mother demilio father demilio sister
demilio
and then starring other systems so much
money even her fans are not going to
want to see that the movie Charlie has
set to start and it's called homeschool
it is a thriller that is being
co-produced by both demilio parents and
also Dixie
oh wow the best in the biz hey best of
the best only the top experienced people
on that one
another comment this is looking really
sharp your work looks very in high
quality I did not read that wrong your
work looks very in high quality Matt
Mayberry donated again uh twenty dollars
thank you Matt but wait dan is there a
chance
I think you owe him an answer
you can put the camera on me
Ian
Ian go ahead
he still hasn't done it here we go
no no chance
well you heard it here buddy no chance
come on Dan this is one of your list
wait what is this uh Philip DeFranco
interviewed Logan Paul who accused Bad
Bunny of exploiting Puerto Rico
what the [ __ ] was that sentence that you
did yeah that came out during the show
was that a Ryan Kavanaugh comment
apparently Philly D interviewed Logan
Paul who accused Bad Bunny of exploiting
Puerto Rico okay so I do know that
Philly D because I'm a huge fan did uh
interview Logan Paul I have not watched
it yet yeah it's something about like
Logan condemns tax something in Puerto
Rico and Bad Bunny he says is exploiting
it isn't that what he's doing well
that's that's the thing is we'll see
isn't that why he's there that's what we
thought yeah we love poets I gotta see
that clip man
dude you can't just go out and talk [ __ ]
on Bad Bunny people die for that guy
I cannot in my head I keep replaying
this is an absolute gorgeous this is
enough this is absolutely gorgeous the
best comment
I just want to have Cavs comments here
this is an absolute gorgeous so by the
way Amy put it put a tab in that I want
to see what Logan said about Bad Bunny
okay
um there it is guys fun fun show
I got Bad Bunny is Puerto Rican by the
way he is a native of Puerto Rico he's
from Puerto Rico oh Ed yeah she's a
[ __ ] colonizer that moved there so
you don't have to pay 10 state tax or
maybe federal too I don't know
Puerto just landed in L.A oh [ __ ] I
gotta see this okay let's watch it now I
land in La after a 32-hour flight from
Berlin so funny to be in the same city
as y'all love you 32 hours how many
layers you have Jesus Christ yeah well
welcome hope you have a good time
welcome welcome
I'm sending you Mike
energy
hopefully you can feel it living all
right this is wild Logan Paul accuses
Bad Bunny of exploiting Puerto Rico
claims Bad Bunny is privately using the
same tax program he is publicly
condemning [ __ ] you did not
dude what okay here we go
Bad Bunny is a Puerto Rican living in
Puerto Rico who is privately taking
advantage of the same tax program that
he is publicly condemning
I I know this and I see how does he know
that like what information are you privy
to did Bad Bunny the tax Hole uh thing I
I didn't see that he's got people yeah
oh you haven't seen the last the latest
on
bad bunnies attitudes about Puerto Rican
tax code I didn't track that carefully I
did not no I have no no it hurts and and
some there are local Puerto Ricans who
know about this so he he feels called
out because he's a scumbag piece of [ __ ]
white colonizer who moved there
to [ __ ] not pay taxes
he actually just lives there like 51 of
the year he doesn't actually want to
live there he just wants to have a
property there so he can save money on
taxes so I'm kind of at a uh lost for
words right now
so I see this I see this music video
that has stuck me in the middle of it
that that surrounded like he's in a
music he put Logan Paul in a music video
what have I missed I missed all of this
so I I I'm of no use to you here this is
really something we should come back to
this on Friday after we figure out
what's happening
we're gonna be late to the game by
context Run The Cutting Edge of this
[ __ ] let's just figure it out live
right love like this could be a good
highlight this is a great highlight
we're trying to figure it out it's
timely we can't wait till if we till
Friday the story's dead bro I found it
if you if you want of course yeah I want
it okay here we go what is a Bad Bunny
musician oh
just I know who he is he just thought
yeah oh uh it's a ill-behaved rabbit
obviously um
xxxtacion
what the [ __ ] is going on okay so let me
finish this no that's a good buddy
that's a good bunny don't put that on
the bunny in Puerto Rico and again
we're not seeing any of this either hold
on we were deep in bunnyland all right
we're good we've recovered yo this
thumbnail is kind of goes hard
can you send me the thumbnail
uh just an image of it
of the Philly D one
yeah yeah
sure sup you beautiful bastards welcome
so where's the thing of him 348 okay
here we go
I'm moving to Puerto Rico it also
touches on a lot of the other issues
that the island faces like Gringos
buying cheap oh so he made a documentary
for properties that locals would use for
housing and making them rentals for
tourists and after Today's Show I'll
link to it down below I I cannot
recommend you we gotta watch that that
sounds interesting yeah dude Puerto Rico
gets absolutely what
I'm just laughing at this scramble to
like figure out what the [ __ ] is even
happening with the story okay so what I
have a ascertain I thought I said
something stupid which is no no yeah no
so this look at this thumbnail bro go
home
he's eating a banana
got him
good one
yeah so Puerto Rico let me tell you
about banana if Puerto Rico
this is strangely appropriate
yeah if you guys don't know Puerto Rico
is a territory of the United States they
however don't have a representative it's
really [ __ ] up actually they're not
they're not a state they're not a state
in fact I mean one thing that we used to
say during the American Revolution is no
taxation without representation and here
we are again
um
but also they're always they're just
always getting [ __ ] by natural
disasters too and
the United States basically treats them
like a bastard child
even though they're technically part of
the the country
um it's a really weird situation
very little I mean Trump went there and
threw paper towels in the face of like
the biggest tragedy they've ever faced
so disaster notable among these being
Logan Paul who has reportedly been a
resident for nearly a year now after
building a 13 million dollar home there
which is why we've seen so many locals
criticizing him other critics saying hey
Logan Paul don't you live in Puerto Rico
sucks how you call it home and the
natives your neighbors are suffering as
well as Logan Paul and all you
millionaires where the [ __ ] are you at
now what are you doing for Puerto Rico
to help want to keep buying property all
of yous are full of [ __ ] well this is
something that we've talked that's a
good point I mean yeah if you're going
to call it your home so you don't pay
taxes
when it gets hit by a natural disaster
where are you helping out the
why do you keep saying that
are taxes like known to be super low in
Puerto Rico there's a that's there's a
known tax loot no it's not they pay
taxes there right but there's some tax
loophole where people from the mainland
go there I think they wanted to motivate
people to move there or something I
don't know the details but there is some
crazy tax loophole where if you move
there you save you get you pay way less
tax and that is why they moved there
interesting it's called act 22 I time
stamped it in bad Bunny's video and he
shows Logan got it wait where's bad
Bunnies video oh this is it it's his
music video for L and life focuses on
millionaires like Logan Paul who are
exploiting
um
I say good for him that's awesome yeah
with their lack of paying taxes dude
that's awesome that he's uh doing this
and that's what
sparked Logan Paul
firing back got it
but for him to say Bad Bunny you're
doing the same thing how the [ __ ] do you
know that well he says everybody on the
island knows also I don't think that's
true because Bad Bunny is a Puerto Rican
native and I don't think that they have
the same offer
what a douche bro just accept the
criticism save in for the wealthy in
Puerto Rico
says there's a law in Puerto Rico where
I'm sorry I missed that where foreigners
to avoid paying certain taxes when they
move here
it's called act 22 which is now part of
act 50.
let me just mute it because it's or
turned it down a lot with this law when
someone moves to Puerto Rico
they don't pay any capital gains taxes
on things such as stock cryptocurrency
and real estate there it is right we
need to launch this dumbass oh gotcha oh
what a surprise
been a rug pull I'm moving crypto coin
and moved to Puerto Rico at the same
time here's one guy bragging about it I
live in Puerto Rico zero percent capital
gains
capital gains is 15 or 17 percent
something like that yeah Pokemon card in
his hat
why'd this dude look like Jim Carrey
everyone looks like Jim Carrey lately
you don't see it
so I think it's a good point it's like
you came here to benefit from this tax
situation and now the whole island is
[ __ ] by natural disaster and where are
you you want to call this your home like
hey come on I think it's an interesting
point he's making
um
I mean whatever isn't paying taxes like
civic duty I don't know why it's like
cool to skip out on
paying tax fair share of taxes
but uh
here here is when they mention him
is
we already saw him it was just that
brief so they just show them yeah they
just they use him when they were talking
about millionaires I think it's cool
unless it's further in but I've watched
about a minute past that yeah no I think
you're right I think it's super cool
he's using his influence
I'm moving to Puerto Rico yeah it's like
the old yeah they nailed your ass bro
I mean look
you did it face the music it looks bad
you look kind of [ __ ] pathetic for
doing that
talked about in the past that the person
that has blown this up the most recently
is Bad Bunny if you didn't see recently
turned his elapagon music video into a
documentary about the struggles Puerto
Rico faces and heavily focused on
millionaires like Logan Paul who come to
avoid many taxes
okay so now we have the full context so
now let's go back and watch
Logan pause
or I'm trying
here he is
all right you can be able to piece this
together uh love
is a portal of course of course okay so
here is Logan Paul responding
yo I hope Bad Bunny sues this
[ __ ]
if he's a native of Puerto Rico it
doesn't sound like he can it says it's
for foreign
foreigners moving there
Bad Bunny is a Puerto Rican living in
Puerto Rico who is privately taking
advantage of the same tax program that
he is publicly condemning
is that true I I know this and I see how
do you know that bro
we need receipts [ __ ] he stepped to bed
Bonnie I'm [ __ ] bro oh hell no I ride
for Bad Bunny man show me the text yo
you ain't got Texas [ __ ] that's a huge
accusation and by the way I love how
he's not like
trying to defend his actions it's like
oh well he did it too he also literally
says Islanders know about it huh
what is that some racist ass dog whistle
[ __ ] Ohio ass white [ __ ]
Dan back me up Dan thoughts
I'm surprised whether I don't know I
don't know I'm surprised Logan Paul's
not knowing anything about pulling
weights out of a fish right now he's so
[ __ ] white guy
it's kind of hard to talk about Logan
now because
We Like Mike yeah I love Mike so much I
like Mike I know my proxy it's like
sorry what was that I just don't feel
right Mike knows he's a scumbag
no he's just being he's just a good guy
and I see things like this and it hurts
and and and some there are local Puerto
Ricans who know about this so I see this
I see this music video that has stuck me
in the middle of it that that surrounded
by context that makes me look like a
vulture in Puerto Rico and again while I
love Bad Bunny I I cannot personally
support the the hypocritical nature of
his exploitation
dude you this is the biggest like even
if he's right which I doubt he is
dude you're you responding to a
criticism is not accusing someone else
you gotta [ __ ] answer what they're
saying you're doing you're saying you're
not a vulture explain how you're not a
vulture explain how you're not
exploiting
to Puerto Rico
you know yeah you're ready just kind of
side steps of it that that's like so
maybe he addresses it and maybe there's
a longer what what does that part of
this what does Bad Bunny being a
hypocrite have to do with the charge you
know what I mean I don't really give a
[ __ ] but thanks for letting me know
um also
I forget
wow did Phil really put in like the
spooky whoa
Phil Phil no he got us I'm curious he
got his ass to school the spooky month
it's October yeah I'm curious if Logan
reached out to Philly and was like I I
want to do an interview on your show or
if Philly reached out to Logan and was
like do you have anything to say that's
interesting I do wonder that too
but he got his ass to scoop man for real
look at that listen to that music while
I love Bad Bunny I I cannot personally
support the the hypocritical nature
nobody's asking you to support the
hypocritical nature just answer the the
accusation [ __ ]
that's a straw man
with his exploitation
[Music]
cinematic impact I believe that yes it's
an impact yes we love the impacts so
sick so is this why Logan Paul's
trending
living in Puerto Rico dude by the way
he's going to get I'm just calling this
now he is going to get skewered for this
take absolutely massacred the bunnies
this this this this is a nuclear take
and it's similar to the one he had about
get out or nope the new note movie for
no reason he goes this movie [ __ ]
sucks dick it's the worst movie I've
seen on Earth this here we never have
like a super rich [ __ ] celebrity
influencer who's clearly gone there to
avoid paying taxes now sidestepping
criticism to accuse Bad Bunny one of the
most beloved musical artists out right
now it seems Universal acclaimed people
love his ass who went out of the way to
make a really good documentary to raise
awareness to his country slash State
plus territory whatever Puerto Rico this
is so bad
here here's the top comment using an
actual Puerto Rican native to deflect
this crazy Bad Bunny is not the one
contributing to gentrification in Puerto
Rico
dude he's gonna get skewered I'm telling
you right now
this is going to be bad for our boy here
Logan Paul's really coming at a man who
was born and raised in Puerto Rico bro
that's what just blows my mind the dude
is from Puerto Rico
it's not the same it's already not the
same like sir how does that even make
sense Logan Paul moved to Puerto Rico
for tax reasons Benito could have moved
anywhere in the planet with the money he
has but chose to stay home that's legit
that's true girl preach it
you're there part-time [ __ ] you're
there 51 and any extra percentage you're
out
if Bad Bunny uh was exploiting Puerto
Rico and benefited he would have he
wouldn't make a documentary calling out
people taking advantage of it yeah
there's no way he's right about that
there's no way
right
that'd be so insane if Bad Bunny did
that
the tax incentive Bad Bunny benefits
under act 20 are not the same incentives
that the vulture and outlier Logan Paul
benefits from under Act 22.
and that and as I noted Puerto Ricans
are barred from obtaining for doing
absolutely nothing except displacing
Puerto Ricans this is dude watch this by
Friday the story is going to be huge
what did you say act 22 is the name of
it there's all kinds of numbers there's
act 22 there's act 20. it's all [ __ ]
let me see yeah I saw 2022. act 22 seeks
to attract new residents to Puerto Rico
providing providing a total exemption
from Puerto Rico income taxes on all
passive income realized recruit after
such an individual becomes Bonafide
resident in Puerto Rico part of x60 but
yeah it's act 22. what was the one where
they uh what was the ACT where they said
to kill all the Jedis Order 66 yeah
already 66. was it part of that
thank you no okay well we've got to wrap
it up we're going way too [ __ ] long
but one last question here uh there's
somebody left the brownie in the
bathroom what's going on with this does
anyone want to own this brownie yeah I
don't know I just it's open yeah it's
open it's half it's one of those ones
that breaks into brownie in the bathroom
anyone no nobody it looks good I'd say I
eat it but it was in the bathroom so you
eat it I'm not kidding we don't and I
would question myself you're the you're
the one that's drugged up baby I would I
would have suspect it was you yeah have
those in the office I've never seen
anything like that [ __ ] want one here
me too I want one in the bathroom if you
want it
Lena thoughts I know Lena loves it it
had to be someone in the room
Nina wouldn't lie
she wasn't me Lena would never lie
she has way too much integrity
all right thank you for watching
everybody
we'll figure it out and I can't wait to
watch Logan Paul get skewered for being
a piece of [ __ ] you guys remember when
he moved to Puerto Rico and they got
busted for driving their golf carts on
like protected Turtle yeah all right I
forgot how many turtles yeah match
pieces of [ __ ] he can't hide it man
you know
I think it's time to move bro
back to Ohio
just stay in Hawaii bro
white boy white boy
go get some weights out of fish and [ __ ]
all right uh GP coming at you we oh
we'll see you guys tomorrow morning
thank you thank you oh Dad said the
chair has been dropped off at H3 podcast
I guess we'll do that on Friday huh yeah
sounds good
all right Dad we'll look at your chair
on Friday
all right y'all better be good
um thank you thank you see you guys
tomorrow morning Tata love y'all
[Music]